[Music]
you just showed up like you might need
some practice uh you going down for the
count it's going down tonight i do it
all for my family you do it all for the
likes i hit that bell and i'm ready to
fight turn me up turn me up turn me up
they want the belt they don't work and
know don't mess around and i'm hurting
them i say the wrong thing make it
personal you say the wrong thing well do
it live we will do it live welcome to
cowboys fight campaign i have two very
very special guests
to my left the fan favorite the fans
demand you back matt i'll do what i can
long time brother from a very different
mother not mature
that might be the same person yeah now
you tell me about your mom we might have
the same mom for sure and sin directly
across from me is mma royalty the legend
the man the myth
josh war master barnett more myth than
anything else yeah i don't think man i
don't know that's your
your veto's pretty stacked brother yeah
man you're uh i mean you you you're
still in shape you look [ __ ] good man
you know what shape yeah
dude you came in here exactly how i
thought you would look
for he did yeah like like white and
blonde
you know though just like blonde right
now i mean this is reddish but this is
yeah dish water i mean the war master it
just it just works man you know like
this whole hit up it works the uh
the nickname was given to me by the band
bolt thrower yeah and uh they have a
song and an album called warmaster so
you don't get to pick a nickname it has
to get given to you correct there you go
so anybody that nicknames himself
you're a [ __ ] loser yeah yeah you're
a tool yeah if you nickname yourself
you're a bit of a you're you're a joke i
totally agree but um
uh so i i went with it and at that point
there was no babyfaceness to me anymore
my nose was was like mulholland drive in
terms of it's
on my face and and i scars and other
[ __ ] and getting gray hairs and it's
like nah
that that that one's not gonna fly
anymore no
war master just makes sense you know
like you you look at your career and
your body of work especially as you
start going like it's just yeah it's you
man
practice firearms training knives sticks
everything i'm trained with swords i
drive muscle cars i i beat people up for
a living so yeah i guess warm master is
apt yeah well i'm glad you're here man
i've been a fan from the sidelines for
quite some time i told matt that you're
like who else who would you want i'm
like dude i'd love to get josh barnett
on here that's like legit yeah when i
was like that guy you'll get that
settled yeah and that's just goes let me
send him a chat on myspace
i'm in his top 16. yeah
it was top 10 i got him man
but it was a it was a easy drive for you
huh yeah it wasn't hard at all you know
i just uh
on the 134 and then the 101 and here we
are
here we are plus uh traffic wasn't bad
either i mean going back the other
direction like [ __ ] those guys i feel
sorry for that
but once we leave here that that
traffic's going to be done yeah but you
just been
since you've kind of got out of the
fight game it's been slanging whiskey
bourbon rum
whiskey bourbon rum vodka um doing
professional wrestling running my own
professional wrestling event
uh
always involved in the car culture stuff
and you know working with uh auto mag to
they're bringing back they brought back
the 44 auto mag and hopefully there'll
be a
perhaps a josh barnett edition and
you're out here you're a gear head all
big time but you're but this is where
we're a little different
i wouldn't consider myself a gear head
because i can't like but you like cars
love cars you know what you don't you
don't have to be
full on elbows deep to enjoy vehicles
nor does it disqualify you from being a
part of the culture for sure in any way
but your car of choice is what what uh
well right now the project that i'm
almost done with is uh and tmi just done
the interior on it and it's gorgeous now
i got to get paint and body done is my
75 formula firebird oh wow that's cool
and it's i
i pulled the old low compression 400
that was in it because in 75 they just
really were not
pumping out any real horsepower the gas
crisis was there it just wasn't
happening so um you know that was like
it was anemic anyway so i i yanked a 455
out of some guy's donor project that he
didn't need and then i had that rebuilt
um i kept it just to an overbore
which is just clean up and then
aluminum heads
uh dual quad fuel injection from phi
tech the thing makes uh 500 at the crank
but it's mainly just you know it's meant
to be a 12 second street car just daily
driver well no no the the hotchkiss did
the whole suspension on we got a nine
inch ford and everything that thing
[ __ ] corner cars okay well wood did
the brakes it's got six pistons in the
front and four in the rear with a manual
set up because i was worried that i
wouldn't have enough vacuum to run a
disc brake booster so it's just based on
the strength of your leg but that thing
will
knowing how la traffic can be yeah and
all the stupid things people might do
it will stop on a dime and it handles
great i put an overdrive [ __ ] in it
it's got a 204r uh but i want to go to
one of these new tkx's and are you doing
a lot of the work yourself i do what i
can but you know the biggest thing is
time did you understand
yeah you really actually understood that
oh dude if you guys do if you fly one of
mine watch like that like everyone can
have tweety birds flying around i
understood none of that but but who else
will get their hands dirty like that is
rogan and sure you've been on rogue
guy too um that he was using when he was
living out this direction that dude's
pretty cool yeah yeah he's a maniac yeah
yeah yeah yeah rogan called me
it was after uh i think the spotify deal
and he goes you hear that and i hear
i'm like
what are you gonna get cobra's on
whatever camaro and he got a uh
a dodge i think it was a one of those
t-rex and he had he sent it to hennessey
has like 850 horsepower he's like it's
faster than my porsche i'm like this is
not good what is your dodge t-rex so
it's like they're they're new this third
version of the raptor for ford oh
okay it's a monster that is little tiny
tires in the front yeah
hennessey gets all that thing and they
trick you out yeah the hennessy vipers
yeah corvettes everything yeah i don't
even know what it is it's a
come on i'm being totally you know an
incredible hulk is too you know you make
the hennessy with the hypnotic and well
i don't know you know what there you go
you'll get that
no hennessy is a an aftermarket um uh
performance company and so they'll take
if you bought a viper
from dodge as it comes you take it a
hennessy and then they will do all kinds
of tuning to it maybe put a different
cam in it trigger and then do different
things to increase its horsepower and
torque and uh probably suspension
aspects all those kind of things so it's
like
people would buy their gt500s and they'd
take them to shelby and they'd get
turned into a snooper snake all right
okay and so um although i didn't go that
route with my gt500 i worked with
centerforce and other people and whipple
and lethal performance and i built what
i wanted was a
a bolt-on
only
street car that looked
essentially stock
but was not all tricked out custom
one-off none of that you want like a
sleeper well it's not good
but sleeper to the point of yeah well it
was the whole point of this car was to
compete in the optimal ultimate
streetcar invitational which i did all
day and uh um you know it makes it makes
seven 700 to the rear wheels on like
13 or 15 pounds of boost
uh mostly stock motor except for the
whipple on it and it's not even the
biggest one they make
uh bmr did all the suspension i put a
lightning drive shaft in it and uh
wilwood did the brakes on it uh recaro
did the seats i yanked as much weight as
i could out of the car without
getting crazy yeah like again i said
it's got to be
anybody could do it if they had the time
in the wrenches in space and you know
that thing is scary streets of willow i
can do
yeah it's a mine's an 08 or an 0-9 at
streets of willow it'll it'll go
over 120 it'll go like 120 miles an hour
in the short street that goes up uphill
man
yeah the full big track it'll it'll top
out the speedometer at 160 and just peg
it just keep your monster yeah and then
that's that's a little hairy because you
got to stop you got to slow down to go
yeah hell yeah into that first turn you
know you know shelby was out of venice
california for a long time people don't
realize it yeah venice used to be kind
of a bit of a cultural city used to be
had an area called thunder road and down
there was all these different
performance uh
manufacturers people that were making
like i think they made lolas which were
a
class of a type of um
homologous race car all these different
manufacturers for racing road racing
drag racing everything was all down
culver city in this area called thunder
road
yeah there's some badass history back to
you yeah la habra you that's where john
force and all them used to be um my
buddy who had a shop down there would
tell me oh yeah every now and again like
some guy you know they're moving their
dragsters around they're going to light
them up down the harbor boulevard or
what have you really just for fun some
some like rich race dudes built
mulholland just to take the race cars
down that's where like mulholland
started and obviously it's all fancy now
but my home's like the the wine
road yeah it basically connects all the
way across the hills to things like what
brentwood canyon or whatever and then
you've got uh
uh laurel canyon like there's these main
thoroughfares will go over and across
into the studio city or into sherman
oaks or whatever and mulholland connects
all the way across all those some rich
dude who's like had all these race cars
is the one who did all that right but it
was so they could race down that that's
wild
yeah nuts i got a whole lot of
california lessons right now yeah yeah i
mean tell us a little bit about you yeah
we're going to work on a car a little
bit about indiana indianapolis yeah
that's about it yeah
that's about it the combines today
minneapolis today that's right the
combat but you see a lot of the combine
because they were enforcing like a lot
of coveted rules
a lot of agents like we're out man yeah
so i don't even try to keep them in a
bubble how nuts is that yeah dude how's
that gonna work what if it's one of
those bubbles where if you get it
rolling and you're inside it you can run
into other people right here
super fast safety suck the mask inside
his mouth because he's breathing so hard
did you hear about the dude well first
of all brendan told me about some dude
around like a 4-3 or something that's
the record yeah 4-3-1 or something like
that which is ignorantly funny which i
thought the record was dionne or what's
his name
the teal back from chris henson yeah
yeah i thought it was him
me too i thought but then uh on
google is like fastest 40 i don't know
um i know didn't they say that but that
dude you sent me he's what's six eight
two three six six three forty one ran a
479
a d tackle from georgia
boys are getting out of control i mean
how is that even real i mean out of
control
yeah although that's fine the one caveat
i'll say to that is
running that 40 is running that 40
in a in a very controlled
set
space correct you're not gonna run that
dude is not gonna hit a four what do you
run a four what four well a four seven
four seven nine he's not touching four
seven nine on that field dude he's not
he's not running 40 yards on that field
yeah a d london ever now receiver
on the screen yeah
428 baylor receiver taekwon thornton
post the nfl scout connie's fastest
40-yard dash time of the day
okay
there you go but dude let me see
whatever chin pretty sure it's chris
henry or dion i just wrote record but
dion's was back in the day when they
really it was all by hand
they don't count that stuff as much
right oh [ __ ] john ross yeah oh i never
heard of john ross before uh he came
from out of washington i think that is
so fascinating chris johnson rondell
menendez at four two four you know
what's weird so fast is a lot of times
those guys that run that fast they just
don't work out yeah they're only good
straight ahead we had a difference then
there used to be uh there was a guy that
was a part of the us olympic track team
hershey uh no well yeah hers was a part
of everything yeah commercial herschel
does everything sure yes no he's he's
got a president he produced yeah he's
probably like he fixes cameras in his
spare time have you ever when he eats
his one meal it's like have you ever sat
down and like spoken with him yeah he
had tons
of his life is insane dude
dude like the stuff that's worked out
like it's literally like foursquare like
the right right person at the right time
right space boom this phone his lap i
mean it's crazy dude yeah but uh there
was a guy i cannot remember his name he
might have played for the seahawks at
one point he's a wide receiver the dude
was fast as [ __ ] but
he didn't run the routes as well as
other guys he didn't have that touch
that feel out there because it's not
just about how fast you know right
because a lot of these other guys are
close enough in speed and like i said
running the 40 is running the 40.
running the 40 is not running when a
guy's in your face hitting you you got
the the all these things change like all
of a sudden you got a ball in your hand
or you're not running like this anymore
all your form is broke yeah you know
you're not hammering back and all that
because the combine's a little
old-school when you think about it it is
it's it's antibiotics for sure but like
um like i said i think the broad jump is
relevant i think that 20-yard shuttle is
relevant yes um i think the lg is
relevant for athletes yeah um i think
that the vert is explosive because it
shows your lower body the 225 is
relative i mean i almost think they
should do either more weight we should
do 315 probably especially for up like
o-line d-line should be 3 15. for like i
think two or they should change it to
incline so you know well or yeah they're
making more sense you know i think
240 pounds or heavier do two or three
like a sled block drill yeah
i think boom
those explosiveness positions yeah and i
think that they should do that like like
coming out like um almost like a push
press but on like a like it controls
your motion on it so you can't get hurt
but when they have like stuff like that
because that shows how functional you
transition
drop weight like have a set weight for
it like uh 300 pounds yeah that's your
general you know alignment you're going
to run across hit it and then time how
far they drive it yeah because like
how distance and time yeah because that
guy who's like 378 pounds then do 225
does like 57 times like we he's never
going to be blocking his 225 pounds dude
we had we had a dude for when i was at
the before he's not going to be blocking
him
no yes yeah in fact this
is is [ __ ] like what third compared
to everything else for your point even
in class yes more so yeah because you
think about past blocks that's what i'm
saying like a push press makes more
sense like you're here in some kind of a
position and you and you come out yeah
and drive blocking makes so much
difference hit hit and it shows you how
well you're transferring you're like
guiding somebody because if you're
trying to pass blocking by fight like
literally trying to stop him yeah you're
screwed that's not good if you if you do
it once or twice like there's no way i
if i could pass block you if i try to do
that if i get it once ain't gonna happen
the second time you're gonna start
ripping on the other side you're gonna
start swimming or doing something else
or you're gonna catch inside the pads
trying to chuck me off i can't like over
the length of a game i care how big and
strong you are how quick you are if
you're trying to match mass with mass
and if you're really let's say you're
this this
phenomenal unreal athlete that can do it
okay then they'll that coach will just
start rotating guys on you and bust your
ass up for sure it's just not gonna work
so pass blocking is mostly tell me if
i'm wrong it's about guiding right it's
like not letting them get to the inside
line correct and
a bath and i've noticed i have beautiful
balls our friends at manscape the global
leader below the waist hygiene are
turning men's shower dreams into their
favorite routine with an all new ultra
premium collection this is an all-in-one
hygiene skin and hair bundle is designed
to upgrade the everyday man shower
routine from head to toe your skin your
hair your balls deserve this fellas come
on bros save big by going to
manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping with a code cfc do we have
favorite routines while we're showering
because if this could create one yeah
that's pretty impressive of itself i
mean it could have all kinds of
attachments yeah dude we're talking
we're having a landscape you got a few
things you could probably add to this
whole equation dude you're right warm
master
you're so frightened
they have everything though man you got
dry skin you got hair problems you got
cologne they got body wash the cologne
infused
fluid conditioner that's the only [ __ ]
that men can get away with by the way
only dudes can do two dudes can do that
yeah it's usually frowned upon yeah wash
our ass with it too yeah it doesn't
matter that's how that works and i'll
drink it anyways uh this new bundle will
change your life and listen we want all
the listeners and viewers of cabba's uh
calabasas fight command to live their
best life so get 20 off and free
shipping with the code cfc manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with a
code cfc
manscape.com.com it's time to get wet
and clean with the new manscape shower
routine okay
they wanted that to rhyme but wet and
clean doesn't really
matter that was a mouthful for me now
they were kicking the the ufc 272 main
card you have no gag reflex that was
pretty good not bad right dude you're
not mad at it but they're kicking off
with heavyweights josh how
you said you don't watch a ton of
fighting anymore no no never
are you are you one of those guys that
even when you were fighting you weren't
like balls do you know um
i mean
i was at least hitting the cervix early
on okay but but at this point um
you just want to get away from an hour
we've seen it all before like there's
nothing greg hardy's going to show me
tonight that i've never seen that's new
that is going to like blow me away
especially on the ground though well it
doesn't matter it could be
my when i
my my last sparring partners in boxing
were prince charles martin uh joe hanks
uh ross vancouver all these pros like i
was at henry tillman's gym under uh
jamal jamal doula sparring guys in
straight boxing josh
uh was a world champion he actually i
mean him sparta together at boxing in
santa monica but he went on so he won a
world champion guy rolled his ankles a
little dicey how he got his championship
and then he fought anthony joshua and
kind of got dealt with that that was
that was just too much it really wasn't
that just that was a mental thing
but
after that he was beating uh ruiz yes oh
the big fella he's the cuban joshua
right yeah or no he gave him static no
not not that sorry
dropped him like twice
that's yeah so you know
so like
so now hearties
expect him to get now see i love this
spivak guy also there's two
killer romanians
are no wait there's a remaining
card there's a romanian undercut
moldovans yes that's what they are
they're moldovans it's which
not trying to piss no romanians off but
technically moldova was part of romania
for most of of history uh
was uh part of uh at one point when you
have vladimir paler was in velocia you
had stephen the great his cousin was
running moldova and he never lost a
battle stephen the great in fact even
against the turks really yes
i didn't expect all this history
information here you guys are killing me
today he needs to write a book but
i like this spivak kid i i really dig
him i love his approach throwing guys
getting on them
yeah this goes to the ground yeah now
his
striking is not spectacular but i'm
going to go out on a limb and even
though i haven't watched a lot of greg
hardy
i'm going to say his isn't anything
impressive either
his grounds
well no but his striking is no strikes
he's just an explosive big head he can
outlet a guy he's big he's got 80 inch
reach which is which is nice to have
yeah but
yeah let's see what happens if he gets
his he hasn't shown him he hasn't shown
to have too much fight here he has he
like he kind of rushes you know what it
is he got in the game and you know this
looks like that's better
greg hardy got in the game so late
there's not enough hours in the day for
him to download that i don't care who
he's training with what camp even if you
were training him every day he doesn't
have enough hours in the day to download
what he needs to take this experience
most of the time when me and matt were
training together of course we'd have
our hard rounds we'd have our technical
stuff but then we're spending
tons of time on feel and experience and
just like no you need to get the reps
it's wraps it's reps it's wraps it's
raps he would he would he would hit the
pause button on me so often like um we
have to go do this and he would like
take me out like out of the out of the
work and be like when you get designed
because you just don't have that feel
yet yeah and then i was like there's
holes in your game i was like seven
years deep in the game and he's like you
don't have it yet so we would go over
there and he would just be a practicing
dummy for me and just like literally
like let me work on stuff until he felt
that i had the proper pressure and if i
didn't we'd go back the next day no i
mean experience is key man it's so cute
there's really
it's it's tough and i you never know i
feel for greg hardy because it's tough
to get experience in the ufc for sure
like i was just you were that mean you
were the same way i was learning while i
was in the ufc so you're basically in
the nfl trying to gain experience
you know being in the nfl that's another
example once you get to the nfl
getting to the nfl
really isn't that isn't the
accomplishment that's not [ __ ] yeah you
need to be in the nfl to be an nfl
player yeah and that's it and a lot of
times there's plenty of guys that could
that could have had all kinds of careers
at the nfl that for one reason or the
other generally arbitrary
oh they didn't get to stay because
someone made a choice here there it's
like oh you know but i have to choose
between these two guys and this guy's
two inches taller so it's like yeah come
on really does that really make the you
know make him fight and then pick that
guy yeah if you're asking me but all
right we got spit back and you know what
i like hardy going with that low kick
right off the bat he's athletic and this
is something you know obviously harley
has a lot of hate because you know he
came in a lot of baggage with his
daughters his backpack yeah he had a bad
pass that's true but you know but what i
do hear from a lot of people that train
with him says he you know and he's a
sponge like he trains his ass off he's a
changed guy
he's not with america there can be
redemption this is true i mean it coming
back from from the things that that got
people so hot at him in the first place
where he generated all this heat it's
pretty serious stuff but
a person can be
just as serious about redeeming
themselves and becoming a better person
that's how things should work and you
know fighting sad is strangely enough
can be a venue for that because
oh
beautiful title oh sheep i spit back
that judo background is so cool that now
he's locking up that side choke already
it looks like but he's up against the
wall so it's gonna be tough to finish it
very tough uh but look he's taking those
posts apart taking those posts apart you
know what's amazing you got rashad evans
in his corner but you know what's
amazing to me is greg hardy for fans i
don't realize this greg hardy worked i
don't know eight weeks and they're like
don't get taken down early on
we are a minute fifteen yeah yes you you
know that and that's so deflated
if your whole strategy is don't let this
happen
that's there's nothing worse you're like
well you're my best and as soon as you
get to like get up doing your thing and
it's like god don't rest all right i'm
gonna rest just for a second you know
what he's in the back room like warming
up he's like i just you know don't get
taken down early and then as soon as
that hits bivax just all over him but
now hardy's up against that wall he's
able to get back to his he got up
didn't take much of a beating but
here's the thing about hardy too like
nfl eyes dude he was all pro dude
he was a serious stud player man
like super stud
dude that is the worst when they block
that front leg
well because the guy starts leaning
forward to not get picked up right and
all of a sudden you just take them with
their weight but uh and spivak's just
all
he's been hurt because he's not moving
no yeah he didn't know what to do the
first shot i think when spivak turned
him after the half it hit him clean
buzzed him up and he just was
it's like uh you know someone you know
had him close his eyes and stick his
head on the bat and spin around for 20
times and then he's easy to know where
the hell is going on uh and i do really
love whoa he just woke up oh yeah
concussed
he saw ghosts so he was like ah oh my
god that's that's rough um it's it's
tough to you know you gotta for dana
it's tough what you do with greg hardy
cause you know obviously there's a lot
of baggage with him even though he's
getting better he's lost a bunch of
fights in a row now yeah well i mean
their heavyweight division is pretty
thin
it is which is odd to say about a bunch
of fat guys fighting like us
[Laughter]
that was such a good job dude yeah he
was too casual once he got out of this
he was too casual well yeah he really
needed to aggressively get out of there
spivak using the glove to pinch was able
to keep him in control and that
underhook had had hardy lifted up even
though hardy 6'5 spec's tall enough from
from his hip to to to shoulder ratio and
then that half nelson took him over and
i think it's the first left hook
but also for a hearty it's like if you
know you're dealing with a guy who's
good at those throws and the grappling
like that you don't want to rush in he's
going to use that against you and that's
what he's doing and what's funny is
judo will often be a completely
different problem that can be more
difficult for people to deal with
because one where do you find a judo guy
to prep you for it two
stopping a double especially with a cage
is easier to train for yeah and you see
it a lot more the judo like i i traded
with ishii who's a gold medal winner man
when he was at range yeah he was my
student for years was he really yeah the
nicest guy of all time great guy and he
had a decent single but that oh soda
guardia his bro so that's he wrestled he
wrestled frank muir yes uh he wrestled
frank mir in quintet and when frank gets
and i'm coaching he she against him so
when ishii hits his osoto and when the
match is over i talked to frank and i go
nobody really stops that yeah i mean i
tried to because i have a judo
background as a little bit as well i
tried to osoto ishii all the time just
to see if i could do it and yeah he
would oh sorrow my soda he's built like
a fire hydrant and then
if you knew it was like once he because
he was that rain like like three four
times a week so we knew kind of how to
negate it yeah but if a new guy came in
i don't care who you were yeah all
american wrestler penn state whoever
yeah we would literally just stop and
watch him because he was taking him for
a ride you just see him go
strong as [ __ ] and his judo technique i
mean he's a gold medalist yeah really
golden oh yeah legend in japan you know
who else uh so when i fought yoshida
headlines i used to train with him all
the time at
sushi kosaka's gym and i remember
seeing him on these new year's eve shows
in japan where they would have all these
different athletic competitions and they
would have even some some people from
abroad come and show up and they had
different segments well one of them
was strength there was a couple of them
actually that were strength based right
yeah and so ishii would or not sorry
yoshida competed in a couple of these
right right like there was this one that
was a um a tug of war thing where they
had a harness on them and a rope
and the rope was coiled up between the
two and they're facing away from each
other in the in the the the launch
position right there's the square
they run off
and then you gotta get to
but you're facing away right
yoshida won every single strength
competition against him
yeah no he beat like a football player
rugby guys it didn't matter like he beat
every single one of them and i remember
training with him trying to finish a
double wrist lock on him and just being
like how is this guy this [ __ ] show
this is insane he thought he went on
fight fedor crow cop like he had a great
career yeah really yeah i think i'm the
only guy to ever submit him
i was just going to say that he no he's
impossible to finish would you catch him
everyone always did you really yeah
you're a [ __ ] monster
he wouldn't tap because i had him in
other [ __ ] earlier i had these little
nasty like stopper toe holds and stuff
where i'm like crushing on the ankle and
pulling it up from referee's position
different things and he just would not
quit after the end of the fight
uh
i went to the back to to give him
respects and stuff because we were the
main event you know he was part of the
promotion itself where was this at josh
this was that uh
not
wasn't yokohama it was uh
no no no we were at uh it was in tokyo
um
and we did a we hit a record for
attendance
you and him has been a big it was it was
what's that like 80 000 no no it wasn't
quite that big but it was something it's
like 20 something but in a place that
had never seen like yeah it had never
seen that kind of attendance yeah and uh
uh yeah there's there's two
gyms to it now two venues there's a
small one and a large one we did the
large one but i can't remember the name
of it off top my head anyways
uh i go to the back to pay my respects
and everything and you know he's a
friend as well as a training partner so
it's like you know i like
part of fighting friends and matt will
tell you when
bellator tried to match us up and i'm
like
if you want to make money
i don't i'm i'll make you money and if
you beat me i don't whatever like it's
my buddy
but i really i'm going to give this to
you because i'm not into this
and matt's like me neither i'm like well
they already knew yeah i already [ __ ]
told him from the jump
button
but at the same time i'm going i'm not
going to steal money out of matt's mouth
yeah and i don't care if matt stalks me
in the face because one
not new yeah
and two
if you love your buddies
like you can't take yourself you're here
to help them out yeah you know no matter
no matter what it's dicey so it is dicey
and i get it i call it basketball
i'm also a psychopath so i don't care
about these things but but i i'm
considerate to the people i give a [ __ ]
about you are a psychopath and i i'll
never the the and i i mean that in the
most in daring way because i remember i
was with my i was in the ufc at the time
i think i was ranked in the top 10. and
i remember you were fighting somebody in
the ufc and stitch was your uh
my quarter
guy and uh as he spun the vaseline on
you go let me die in there do not throw
in the towel and my coach bumps me and
goes dude
you believe that [ __ ] that you have the
same mentality and i went no no i don't
i went no no i don't and i had so much
respect for you and i went oh no i don't
i said dude
there's so if josh barnett's here i'm
here he's going to die in there this is
what he does he's the war master right
my nickname is big brown
if i get in any trouble i get so much of
the [ __ ] i want to do you throw that
towel faster i won't be mad at anybody
but i remember i was like like i you
there are certain moments in my career
and that's one of them i will never
forget that's one of the reasons i went
on there i'm sure i had so much respect
for you i was like oh i'm not i'm not
like him like that's you would die in
there i would never it's funny it would
never cross my mind
we're segueing a little bit but i'll get
back to it um
we were doing this call uh
you know what they used to do where they
do the press junkets on the phone you
have multiple guys on there and it was
like me benson henderson and a few other
guys
uh and we're talking and i don't know
why it came up about
the old days or other stuff and i'm just
i started in on like yeah well when i
started there was almost nowhere to
fight like the ufc was a thing and there
was some play but how do you get into
any of this stuff so you just did it was
all like ad hoc put it together however
you could a la carte and everywhere
you'd fight we would figure out the
rules when you're there like oh do we
head butt or do we not head butt are we
using gloves
and so we would just
show up and go go at it and i'm just
going to say that so casually i i just
said well you know i didn't do this so i
could be famous i did this so that i
could smash people so i could walk look
up at somebody across from me and go you
think you can [ __ ] take me out yeah
that's enough what were you like growing
up man like where were you like you grew
up in california no where'd you grow up
i'm from seattle that's right you are
from southern ballard yeah so what was
it what was what was growing up like did
you have siblings what was your i have a
eight-year-old sister eight-year-older
sister who used to beat the [ __ ] out of
me okay when i was younger uh but not
for long and then i had a dad mom uh
they were great but they're all like
ultra blue collar folks
my mom came from more of a
higher standard upbringing because her
her father was
uh a big-time lawyer and was the estate
uh assistant attorney general at one
point and all this kind of stuff and
then my dad
is the was the the result of an affair
grew up in the backwoods of southwest
washington
uh street fighting
logging good day long shoring good day
great dad yeah but uh i'm trying to
think where you're but he you know
no no that might i talked to my mom this
one time and i was going you know
there's a part of me
kind of wishes that i could at least
like go back in time at a similar age
whatever and just fight my dad yeah and
she goes
she just looked at me and went ah
he's really me i go i know how
meaningless
and she goes well i i know him and he he
just well shoots you is talk to you
sometimes and i go no i know that you
know my dad telling me a story like the
time he got you know busted for a knife
fight for stabbing a guy and you know
getting a couple day you know a day in
jail for you know to give him a lesson
or like a dad like you he was like six
two and two forty she's a big dude i
mean well he had a stroke
right and
recovering from that his left hand could
squeeze the stroke side could still
squeeze like oh like 140 pounds and his
right hand could could top off the meter
over 200. he's a savage that's a while
and he was he was really quick
and
brutal like uh the stories of him
fighting and it's not just him telling
him it's like everybody's like oh no no
yeah you don't that's where you get it
from well and then he would tell me
stories about hanging out with his buddy
whose brother was called otto the blade
and his dad was like some ptsd
world war ii guy who had a full
automatic 30 carbine that would
sometimes just lose it and start
shooting at them when they're running
you know and they're like running across
the yard is this guy's taking shots at
him and they're just like whatever
that's insane yeah my dad grew up in a
very interesting scenario did he see did
he see like the evolution of korea he
did and you know what the first time i
ever got knocked out because my dad
eventually became a
hazmat instructor for the union so he
had all kinds of training and first aid
and different stuff so he was the first
person back there at the trump taj mahal
i don't know how he got there but he did
and he's checking me over for different
things and he's he's keeping on me and
it's like all right you're good oh so
you guys were close yeah yeah no he's
one of my best friends no did you
russell coming up how did you get in the
catch like how did you get uh i started
wrestling in high school and then i got
to catch when
you did coming up were you your size
were you always i was always big i was i
was like 260 250 in high school running
a 4 9 40
how did i get recruited for football i
did but i was really just like one i got
really
bent out of shape about dealing with
football because i would go to like the
um university of washington football
camps and stuff and i'd smash up on kids
and then i'd see and then when it came
down to it's like i saw they got
scholarships and i'm like why are you
giving this [ __ ] a scholarship i
smash this kid you know this guy from
denver or whatever like i crushed him
like whatever
and well you know we like our linemen to
be at least six five and you're six
three and i'm like yeah but i'm like but
you know and i get it now because the
thought was
regardless wherever they put me
i'm a seattle kid for me to pay tuition
was nothing yeah
2800 bucks or something it didn't it was
so it was easy like why why spend a
scholarship on me when you could get
some potential six foot six 300 pounder
and we're like oh yeah he's baby huey
and you know whatever but we could
probably train him into something and i
remember i told the d coordinator right
then and there i go
line anybody you think that you're going
to give a scholarship to up across from
me and i'll [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of
them and they're just he's just like
that's not what we're doing but i'm just
like i'll [ __ ] punch him in his face
mask i'll tear him apart like [ __ ] that
guy i'll make sure
i'm sure he doesn't make it down right
you know what i mean and they're just
like oh all right
so we got to tell bob the leader
let's go get him out of here man
i mean there was a kid so i used to wear
little fingerless gloves and you know i
was past blocking uh they put me a guard
for one point i usually play tackle on
both ends but uh
we're playing this this school called
o'day who's [ __ ] national champs one
year and we're from this
we have a shitty school but with great
athletes but it's gonna put together so
i'm past blocking this kid and this kid
i'd wrestled against him before and beat
him every time but uh you know he was a
pretty solid football player to a big
kid in high school he was like 280 right
so boom we come off the line i stand him
up on a pass block boom come back boom
and just reel back and punch him right
dead in the [ __ ] face mask
and he goes he's punching me and i go
what are you talking about
and i'm like foot sweep there was a
penalty for sure there was
there was a a move that we used to do um
back in the day that like uh if we're
playing d-line you get it you get out
and if they're like grabbing your face
like face jack and you know um like what
so if people don't know like when you
when you come off a line if you're a
difference alignment you're coming off
the ball um uh i know linemen can face
check you right like they'll take one of
their hands and they'll jam up in your
face mask
and if you go up then you're not you're
not trying to stop your momentum right
you were a tight end uh tied in hvac
yeah you seemed like a titan full back
in the night because
what did you weigh when you were tied in
uh i grew up 40 about 240 245 yeah so
you don't want to be enormous but you're
big enough to block but also tall enough
with big enough hands to catch you know
all your shorts all your flaps all that
stuff strong yeah yeah lower body
everybody both both but then when i was
at cu they wanted me i got to 260 my
senior because they moved me to fullback
so i was like
tell me you hated that just collision
collision i i really remember they're
constantly there oh a 260 fullback let's
take his legs out it's like really yeah
yeah i mean i'll talk about punching
people whatever but you stock a guy in
his face mask he's gonna live you you
you [ __ ] you submarine them in the
knees that's dude so this is some more
war master [ __ ] not as tough as him but
this is listen to this not out of the
way you'll respect this i'm ready i was
the wedge buster on kickoff mm-hmm and
then that's back
yeah right
return okay yeah so but when i think
about it dude when i think back on it
after a game we play like texas or sc or
miami yeah they would we'd have like i
was a fullback we'd run like 98 power
and me versus their linebacker and it
was just a straight concussion and they
would just highlight it every monday
and i think back i'm like hey [ __ ]
like i was your sacrificial lamb dude i
don't think you had to hate that i
wouldn't want to play that at all i was
sore not i mean dude the amount of
ibuprofen i took was nuts that's horse
yeah so mike also is a good buddy of
mine um oh he was a hell of a fullback
oh dude he was like a 250 pounder right
yeah oh dude for sure
yeah
though and he was like he was talking
yeah he's not very tall um and he was
talking before and he's like um he was
like dude he's like i loved my job he's
like he's like but he's like i didn't
mind blocking at all he's like but he's
like if they gave me the ball he's like
i would just he's like i would be
[ __ ] related i mean he was like and
like and that's why i asked him i was
like i was like how do you feel that
chris berman affected your career
because remember because so high on him
right right yeah every time you run yeah
he's like you know what he would talk
about everything yeah yeah
one yard run yeah you know whatever and
he was like he's like i feel that chris
berman built my person up so much my
persona he's like that tampa was almost
forced to give me my third contract yeah
keep me there
because i was a staple and then i was
such a he's the face of the and he's
like
he said chris berman had such a role in
that because he built me up so much
because he loved the way i said it was a
hell of a pair right i mean
uh i mean they're just they were so good
opposites in terms of running style
clearly but perfectly paired oh dude um
he was uh what's this what was that the
tailback you just brought up oh well
done work done
i told you this he was the hardest
runner i've ever played that's what he
said yeah hardest runner i ever
go through a whole constant energizer i
thought he broke my damn arm like it
came through like boomerang arms i was
like oh well i was on a block and i
tried to come off a black and boom and
hit my arm and i was like i was like oh
my god i thought my heart broke have you
have you seen the fullback dude it's
rare they use fullbacks these days but
there's a fullback for baltimore he's
six one three hundred pounds oh but not
fat not fat runs like four seven not
ironic remember he's not iron head uh
dude that dude was huge he's him yeah he
was huge dude this guy is insane insane
he's so funny
yeah that's right his son plays for the
steelers and he's all pro
this is the mouthy dude yes yeah i kind
of like it it's a stud though i know
there's something i like to see here i
agree and he and i know
he likes all this chatter is is you know
hey we don't need that but it's like ah
it's not harming nothing it's also but
to me it's like it's it's organic for
him you know what i'm saying so you can
you can tell when it's manufactured when
these guys get on the mic and do those
where's the outdoors and [ __ ] he's out
of uh texas
yeah kevin holland's out of texas and he
but he went to uh ak to work on his uh
wrestling right chin yep he went to ak
to work
on his wrestling oh really probably so
he thinks cormier knows a little bit
about wrestling yeah
smidgen yeah
the um you know what's crazy is that
that he was he was an auxiliary pick for
that um tournament right the one the one
you guys were in in strikeforce oh yes
he was he wasn't original no no he was
he was the alternative but i mean think
about it so he had to replace aleister
overeem correct you know who's out or
played or lost in round one yep like
this is bonkers yeah yeah yeah and that
was the best performance of bigfoot's
career bar not bar none for sure
everything and it was it was really
masterful like that's a bigfoot [ __ ]
spinning knee bar attempt batsman sick
dc talking about fighting bigfoot's so
funny i just did a show with him the
mike tyson superball show yeah and after
we were talking he goes i i don't he
goes i don't get it man he goes you
can't miss he's like bigfoot's head
because bigfoot's head's like this he
goes everything i threw was landing he's
just throwing punches at the driver
that's what he said he's like he's like
dude his face is this big not not to
bring up a sore name between the three
of us i felt that way with ben rothwell
like i felt like my hands were named i
felt like but i feel like
his face was magnets and i just kept
sticking his face and i was like i'm
about to knock his ass out [ __ ] take
him down on this beat him in his own
game not so much dude i wobbled him with
a spinning elbow i faked the the low
single and he came back up with jon
jones style wobbling like oh i got him
and he's like dude i have 60
fights of experience young buck yeah
slow rush you have to uh you have to
overwhelm him with punches you can't
it's not well maybe now it's different
yeah but if you want to knock out ben
rothwell you got to hit him with a
success
successive series of shots non-stop
literally then he'll the one stop
conversationally that alliteration was
impressive yeah i'm impressed by
everybody successful series of shots
that's pretty dude how about how dude uh
obviously that's three man obviously
everybody knows what's happening with
with cain velasquez how crazy is that
man it's you know what you know what
you're taking josh i feel like he should
have hit me up so we could have trained
him up at terran tactical no i'm just
kidding are you boys just kidding are
you boys or tears yes me too me too
yes um but honestly josh here's my thing
you don't have kids right no before you
answer
me and matt have kids if someone
100 i'm with you dirtbag's a dirt bag
but when you have kids this is literally
societally like
society
um
cannot allow for you to mess with
children cannot cannot because it
doesn't start or stop there never it
always it's a sickness you cannot do it
josh my thing is with your skill set if
someone were to harm say a cousin or
nephew or yours whatever
the and i don't know what rage kane had
or the pre-med stuff like that with my
skill set i'm not reaching for a gun i'm
gonna do it with my bare hands i'm i'm
i'm getting the satellite i'm thinking
that i'm killing everybody oh you're not
what are you doing what are you thinking
i'm doing whatever it is that make lets
me do it and get away get away with it
get away with it yeah there you go all
right so there's a premeditated thing
you i you know a buddy who's a lawyer
and i go yeah and i go dude you know
he's obviously
pretty upset he goes you gotta
understand the loss black and white here
it's pre-meditated
he goes if you're a cane fan you got to
pray to god this goes to a jury and the
jury has sympathy
yes which they will he goes a jury well
i i don't think there's no way a
prosecutor can let them go to a jury
because i don't think there's any way
that any jury i almost feel like
you know among all kinds of problems
with the way
our legal system is set up especially in
california
especially in california but i mean it
is generally broken but
uh
there has to be
i really feel like there should be some
sort of carve out some way of
structuring a way that you can kill
pedos agree and it's okay okay so so
check this out so first of all 100 i'm
good with that no problem yes no it's
it's not allowable this is going to take
children just cannot this is going to be
the thing if you or us or any of us get
involved in some sort of thing and and
whatever it it runs to we're grown
adults it's different yeah kids are are
they really are innocent this is going
to take a very very dark turn and we can
pull it out of the way it's already dark
i like dark it's good it's good
out of the gutter
so it's getting dark so i have a good
friend of mine who was a corrections
officer right and then um he said that
uh they started moving all the
pedophiles are getting raped right like
all the rapists pedophiles blah blah
they're all getting ready you destroyed
in prison yeah so good they they they
started a protective wing so they moved
everybody else oh this one where the guy
gets shot leaving the courtroom that's
the that's the father pretending he's on
the phone as the guy
pops out
so my friend sent me this and it was a
hopefully this is the same thing that
happens with kane the father was like
and and
guys
holland's in trouble right now because
olivier is quite a deep well no boom all
right yeah uh so
um so so they got they moved all day
they moved all everybody out of one wing
and moved all the pedophiles into
another
and then i started doing raids on those
pedophiles right because they were all
in there they had no they had no no
enforcers they could do whatever they
wanted to do right
they started finding trading cards
they made toss-off material of trading
cards of the addresses of the kids of
the parents of the siblings of the
stories they did the things they did to
them and they would pass them off in the
prison as toss-off material and he was
like he's like that's when i had to quit
he's like if they were doing nothing to
make those [ __ ] suffer and die
the worst death possible and they would
let that [ __ ] go around he's like i
couldn't do it anymore you got to go
rush on it like i said it got really
dark it got really dark i'm sorry about
that but it's super dark
but for for kane i just i pray to god it
goes to a jury or the
the law has some sympathy when you're
talking about a a family member his
who's four years old molested over 100
times and this guy's molested other kids
why do the parents let that guy be
around because this is the [ __ ] world
we live in where nobody where
everybody's off working everybody's
pulled out of the home no one builds a
home no one has their relatives around
them but what happens when you're your
mom and dad get old or you stick them
out you send them off somewhere you know
what do you do with the with the family
home you sell it and you take the money
yeah instead of thinking like oh and
then you want to complain about oh the
rockefellers are this rich family has
all this stuff well you know how part of
the reason that is because they [ __ ]
kept their land because they oh you know
how much even even when you could say
like well it's cost so much less to own
a house at
earlier points in history it's like yeah
but you don't [ __ ] let it go because
land is a limited resource everywhere in
the world but i don't care when it was
it was still really tough to of course
no matter what look i saw my dad's pay
stubs from working at boeing for when he
was a riveter on 727's he was making
like three dollars an hour nut
it's just like
look don't be in such a hurry to just go
ahead and fill your ass with cash to do
with no purpose cash is simply a tool
yeah right if you don't have if you have
a hammer
but all you have is screws then you're
[ __ ] yeah right it's like
i'm not saying that having cash or
having money is a bad thing not at all
but
for what to do what yeah why and um
you know people are so quick to discard
their parents discard their family
members you know oh well they're old now
and i'll let this hospice take care of
them like why would you want to do that
why would you want your family to die in
the [ __ ] bed that they lived
wow oh wow that is quick and nasty yeah
his arm's in there oh he's fine it's
fine
oh i thought it was around the neck that
was awesome that's pretty dope you look
like you see a little pat from olivier
with a smile i like this this is two
consummate professionals no animus just
fighting it out but my last bare knuckle
match people were asking me about it
yesterday and i just said when was it
joshua poland uh 2020 i went to poland
and fought this guy had a bare knuckle
boxing match with elbows
it was bare knuckles so boxing and you
could throw it album
and who did you fight uh martine
rosowski monster
completely covered head to toe his face
covered in tattoos
uh walk to the ring with a biker gang
with cuts
jesus christ
good dude though oh my god and the guy
is as respectful as it comes really good
dude his face would say otherwise josh
he was cool as [ __ ] and and you know by
the end of it i just remember thinking
i'm so proud and i love this guy to be
in the ring with me because he's on the
same wavelength we're out here trying to
bust each other up and that's great yeah
but but we have a sense of honor behind
it
and no one
it's like well i had to say like you
know you do your interviews your post
fights and stuff it's like i know
someone has to win or lose but i feel
like regardless of the outcome we both
became better men this day and that to
me is is is something that speaks to
that's something more transcendent and
higher you know um i i really despise i
despise what the fight game turned into
um you know why it turned that way and
it's hard not to wait wait meaning um
about entertainment like conor mcgregor
yeah the the oh [ __ ]
dropped him what happened
he dropped him and now he's following it
up he got them back
the the shameless helming of yourself um
i hate the fact that the promotion
stopped promoting oh
great nice that's a big win under
holland huge that was a great family
massive and olivier is as tough as they
come oh i see cam haynes in the back you
know cam haynes at all
i don't know
is that cowboy yeah yeah yeah he's a
cowboy he's tough did he drop weight
because he's like 70. once no he's not
going to do that one he's that's what's
been what's happening holland went up
holland dropped yeah
i like seeing stuff like this this is
this is exemplary all right all right
matt oh wait before you tell the story
did you win that fight josh yes so they
stopped him between the second and the
third what happened awesome uh
i think that he had taken too much
damage he couldn't really see anymore
yeah no i dropped him twice in the fight
or three times yeah two or three did it
did it pay okay or you just did it
paid well and but also it felt like
why i got into fighting in the first
place
you know i wanted it it sounded like the
street fighter 2
kind of
aspect of life where i traveled the
world like oh here's a thai boxer here's
this here's that all right let's go
and uh
i mean i literally fought a guy
from the i met on the internet in the
washington athletic club in downtown
seattle in a judo room with a clock a
lock closed door we agreed on rules and
i fought him
because because you can't because he
because he wanted he wanted the smoke
right
because that's what it was like we used
to on aol we were chats on mma on and no
holds barred and we would talk it up
and people like oh i weigh about this
much as my background i've had this many
all right and people just make fights
yeah yes i started i needed more
experience in between
uh well actually washington athletic
club is like high-end
baller types it's like l.a athletic club
stuff oh wow
where i so this guy's a harvard attorney
this guy's fantastic he's an awesome
dude now was the rule all right if
whoever taps out it's no time limit yeah
we didn't have a time limit jesus that's
so dope dude and that guy's my attorney
and he i ended up submission wrestling
him in a tournament later after that and
it was cool the guy is great i love the
guy that's so dope so um
um
i needed more exp i i fought the first
guy i fought i already had fought pro in
hawaii from amc and i got called on 11
days notice from my old wrestling coach
like hey i know you've been training
whatever you'd be interested in fighting
chris charles i go oh yeah he's already
fought pro in super brawl
when
sure i'll fight him i'll be there
so i figured out like whatever i needed
to get i started training with my old
martial arts coach when i was in town
and just went out there and fought him
and won by front choke in two minutes or
so and then
matt goes that's awesome
what do you call front joke
guillotine okay yeah and then uh
um
matt go matt
matt hume goes hey we want you to come
back in the summer and fight again
okay so i'm trying with jim harrison
over in uh and missoula montana
and
i go okay i need more experience because
next guy bob gilstrap is you know he's
got even more pro he's got pro fights
and all his trains under maurice like
all right so i just would find people on
these mats in in the rec center area
and they're doing martial arts or it's
like frat boys talking about getting
into fights
out in like stockmans and whatever in
missoula and like oh
so
you ever watch the ufc
cool what do you think about it you're
right oh yeah you're into it all right
well hey interested in the fight
no people are like no absolutely okay so
i went and i would just go and fight
whoever i could get a hold of that's so
dope and what the crazy thing was so
there was like a little
room box thing that was in this giant
gymnasium that was like the girls
workout area and they had these little
windows where they could do it be on the
stair climber and they could look out
see what's happening there was a rock
wall there was these mats and then there
was this giant cargo net that separated
like these four full-court basketball
courts
from the mad area and the rock climbing
wall too
this one time i remember
i look i i look over and everyone's
hanging on the cargo nets cheering shut
up as i'm fighting people hell yeah
they stopped playing basketball and
watching this fight
of course but of course and then
whoever's around the rec center and
there had to be cameras in this like
whatever right
i just had a conversation with your boy
me and matt hume have never talked and
then uh a business opportunity came up
and uh he got my number for somebody and
text me he goes hey it's matt hume we'd
love to talk blah blah blah about some
business thing
and uh we've never talked and we
probably talked for 30 minutes about
being a dad and kids and i was like wait
hold on why'd you call like literally
just hanging off being a dad we do
the intention is
to to make one i really want to have a
kid yeah that is
a little warm i'm under i'm under the
gun right now from kayla she's trying to
squeeze out
oh i love it i love it i love it she's
like give me a bun yeah
a little sourdough i already had a
vasectomy so i'm like oh honey it's
gonna be some more reverse oh they're
gonna get in there but she's this guy's
gonna be biting the side of his tongue
she's for real
[Music]
[Laughter]
get you know get your car stereo done
all of a sudden your blinkers don't work
anymore that's that's what's going to
happen
right um i uh you hate the fight because
turn the entertainment aspect a little
yeah
before you i know where you're going to
go with it i think a lot of the change
in the fight game came from
for good or bad came from conor mcgregor
a little bit but
but i think now the game's really
changing is conor mcgregor because
you're right he made so much money he
became so famous every i went well i
want that but
you got it you gotta also but he also
did the work well you gotta be closer to
the world say the things you're gonna
say and then i think that part of
conor's
gimmick we'll call it
was that he because you watch him after
every fight run or lose like all of a
sudden the the rhetoric is is like wow
oh [ __ ] man that is really poignant
stuff that you're saying there's like
some harsh super respectful and and
lovely and just like that's nice
usually yes but um
i think part of that [ __ ] talking is to
put the pressure on himself to have to
perform to live up to
the
the things that he said and i think it's
more about putting it on him some of it
has to be you know um
mental warfare yeah i really do think
most of it is about the pressure on
himself to get him out of bed he'd go
through the training camps oh man i said
this guy you know
sucks dick sideways and whatever and
he's terrible and which is you know to
some degree it's like well if these guys
all suck then what does that mean when
you get them right but you know he just
called out uh makachev yesterday did he
really kind of which yeah it hasn't been
anywhere near a ring and how long now no
dude he hasn't i'm gonna fight this
tiger's secret real quick yeah
you know it's not often i can say that
i've i've uh
popped the top on a tiger thick poured
it in a glass and shoved it down my
gullet but yeah man let's do this um so
my thought is right which you know we're
gonna go your whiskey's amazing though
yeah it's really good man all right and
by the way how do we order it because i
want to order that because i i can't
take any homemorebringerbourbon.com
uh sells out though it does sell out and
so if you want one yep then you just hit
me up okay josh knows again brandon
wants someone yeah he's gotta go i
definitely do yeah
yeah i'm gonna go i'm only sitting here
drinking his [ __ ]
promoting all my stuff
uh what we're gonna say though matt you
can't stand out well i don't like how
the promotion stopped promoting right i
don't like how they put the onus of
putting butts and seats on us our job
right well they don't now though right
well it's espn for sure but i think that
for a long period of time like i
remember when
after i beat kimbo they brought us in to
the summit and they kept x amount of
people for the third day right and the
third day was hey look we think you guys
are going to be the next when i almost
got to fight with tito yes like hey
listen i think you're going to be uh
i cannot wait to hear what you almost
got no fight with tito about yeah
all right so um all right so i uh so i
start uh we go to the segment like
listen you guys are gonna be the next
big personalities whatever else and then
shortly there afterwards is when rhonda
came about and then obviously like he
chased that all around around the planet
and then rhonda realized how much juice
she had because he was chasing her so
hard and that she could do kind of she
could finally say no i don't really want
to do that or this is what i want to do
instead right so she had a lot more
juice and then i think that was the
beginning of seeing the emperor uh
wasn't wearing any clothes like where
like like the the their i think the ufc
realized that they were like hmm they're
giving too much power yeah but then
connor came right and they wanted to get
a hold of the european market and then
conor came along had a hell of a
personality i i knocked out phil de
freeze in 15 seconds and they gave
connor the knockout uh for marcus
brimmage and then once he got it and he
all said he took off and his personality
took off they were like this is our key
because remember they wanted
tattoo ross pearson they wanted ross
pearson to be the dude but he just never
became the guy because he's a great
fighter though
fun to watch right amazing to watch
great technical stuff but he didn't have
the personality but then also remember
there's a huge gap in the european
market because bisping was out right
because he was getting older so they
needed someone to
and that that's where mcgregor came it
definitely made a big difference for the
european market with mcgregor but he
also would make bold claims and then
follow up on that for sure and
he did the work
he took the mayweather pathway which is
you talk talk talk talk talk talk talk
but the problem is
and mayweather has never experienced
this although mayweather's really bright
so don't agree don't about it you need
to understand that not only is
mayweather if you ask anything about
boxing and mayweather or any of his
family members i've talked to roger
before
that guy knows he's a walking talking
encyclopedia about boxing they have
their phd in it
for
yes you've built up all this
anticipation to see you lose because of
the [ __ ] you say or to
um
continue to deliver in these
astronomical claims people stop
believing and as soon as it that loss
happens they're like all right cool
that's it yeah it's always a struggle
with that sort of thing it's like a
magician showing their magic trick with
mcgregor it's a little bit people are
like come on dude but he's so masculine
was that was that what happened with
nate when nate beat him like and nate
was in mexico it made a difference i
don't think it it i don't think it
really took him out i think that was at
once it was the last fight that really
the last fight [ __ ] him that that one
hurt conor yeah
no no no that didn't
even with the khabib fight if you look
back like at the time you're like jesus
christ could be beat the [ __ ] of conor
if you go back and watch that fight
which i've done probably the best outing
anyone's had against could be besides
michael johnson brought like conor
didn't do
he rocked him right rocco yeah i mean
and hunter is great when he's defended
yeah no i mean he he's a savage i love
nate i love the diaz bros are are
awesome like those dudes i am fully in
their corner me too for everything yeah
uh but connor had him sorted that first
round yeah yeah and he got him up too
cocky and arrogant um and and and of
course
a diaz is not going to sit there and go
go back to the corner and just push
harder at the same thing he's going to
make it those kids are born and bred
fighters not just in terms of their
their will or their guts or their
durability but in terms of their fight
iq and their science right and they know
where their strengths are so sure if
they end up in a position where
they're overwhelmed in a in a sector
that they're not able to compete with
that's fine they know that and they know
that they have weaknesses
but those dudes you can't hardly find
better fighters in the entire world
period especially mentally yes um and so
yeah nate made his adjustments and then
won yeah back to your point about the
ufc to me the fighters have the least
power that they've ever had right now do
you think so yeah because of the ufc
deal
i'm sorry the espn deal because now
the way espn works and the the ufc
model's not driven off uh stars anymore
it's driven off delivering 46 but it's
kind of 465 you argue that it's been
that way for
like the last five years and that the
stars
became stars almost in despite of that
agree yeah i agree with that but now the
ufc really now they're not they're never
going to let another conor mcgregor
happen then they would never because
they're like too much power that could
you know ran a stream so you want like
halfway between the two so they can
drive
because rhonda
um
her initial outings as the the linchpin
on a pay-per-view
didn't succeed no correct i mean
i say that only and it's like oh you
only got four hundred thousand compared
to like a condom exactly no she was john
johnson but in enough time then it
started and part of that was not the the
pay-per-views themselves and fantastic
incredible like when rhonda hits rhonda
[ __ ]
it looks like that person didn't belong
in the ring
it's so amazing you know rhonda's
skill set at its apex is
jaw-dropping and her
her uh iq and her mentality and shout
out to travis because i love that dude
he's a good dude took super great care
of me and my fighter when she had to cut
weight for a state title match and mma
and it was thanksgiving and i brought
her over they and rhonda was right there
with water and all like oh i know what
it's like to cut weight yeah travis and
me got to drink beers and hang out and
eat a full meal that's cool you know
beautiful people yeah and and congrats
on having a kid yeah man like we're
talking about it i want to have a kid
yeah you guys have kids they got kids
now i mean yes step it up awesome so are
you saying you're just traveling the
world trying to find women to put babies
in no i have a beautiful lovely woman
okay i intend to put a beauty i tend to
put a baby together
uh
yeah a little while yeah and we just
moved in together okay congratulations i
mean this was and this is uh she was
giving me [ __ ] earlier today and i was
like you know this was my idea right
moving in like no i'm not i'm not
[ __ ] around
i have okay this is stage one this is
two three like i'm not there's a plan
here if we're we're doing this we're
doing it oh yeah um
how old are you
old enough to know better and still
young enough to do it uh 44. all right
well sort of same age
44 i'll be 43 this year wow yeah so
we're the same age is there anything
that in you it's like because for me i
get a little bit worried about damn man
my body's falling apart of course yeah
so like i get worried about that's one
of the biggest things i'm dragging my
feet on because like i get worried that
i'm going to be so old that i won't be
able to go play anything chasing the
kids yeah
but here's the thing yeah you know you
need to realize that as you get older
you get
more dirty tricks yeah you want to learn
how to cheat it even wiser yeah yeah you
have you know how to you know the
shortcuts everything yeah my dad used to
whup my ass as a kid like it was just so
easy for him right you know and and and
even my brother-in-law uh he would
handle me too but uh
right yeah yeah that's in barboza wow
he's still hanging in there he's been in
a long time kick knockout is legendary
do you know for sure but uh yeah god
that poor dude yeah one of the greatest
nuggets oh home dude
he needs to win this though
terry adam's been you know i'm sorry uh
barboza needs to win this one
he's been on a tough who's just who's
the guy from att with him i i know that
but yes he's a good dude i can't
remember um i'm forgetting too
aaron riley i think you should train
with him
um dude aaron reilly by the way
evansville
is it really yes hell yeah how do you
not know that me and mr indie guy didn't
you train with god seeing all of them oh
so chris oh god
cobra right before i only train with
godzilla
cobra compton
no
cobra yes great name no never so i i
trained with gatsey twice he came down
from he lives in hawaii he's hilarious
oh dude he's a trip dude
i mean steepling uh no never oh alex
stiebling so like chris is like the love
of the weekends i love you alex you're a
good dude like chris is the last
mohicans like chris is like the only one
and then like so gutsy comes around and
like dude so i've grappled with chris my
entire life right chris
is like is my mentor right um and uh
every day um he comes in he works he
works his ass off he grapples he has a
great time i have i've never seen that
dude be in a situation that he couldn't
figure a way out of like i'm talking
like he is a troublemaker
dude it's incredible a fire accident a
big hose will get you out of there
that's his mentality for sure so
what's he do now though chris chris he's
a firefighter
yeah this is this is pretty good by the
way thank you sir i like it um i can
tell it's young yeah but it's uh it's
the first like uh japanese whiskey blend
sure
it's really easy to drink yes it's
not overly complex because that can
sometimes actually drive people away if
they're really neophytes to whiskey
but it's
it's it's got
like a nice kind of malty finish to it
which i enjoy and i read the the mash
bill on the back yeah
where's the japanese coming from though
can you even say or no no okay yeah but
it's
aged 10 years in a barrel from japan
there's
not how long ten years
well then i know exactly where it's got
to be coming from there's only a few
there's only you would know if you're in
the business yeah yeah yeah and and
getting
a 10-year stock from any of those
is
it's not just about whatever it costs
it's about whether or not you have the
relationship they would actually let you
have it because japan is hurting like
mad for age stocks of whiskey really
it's been three years just trying to get
that done three years before even but
and literally this is the why don't you
go with multiple k's instead of c's i
mean more than three clearly
it would stand out to have a little
little hood on it and everything but
it's just
probably not a good look
oh you want to hear about aztec warrior
[ __ ] so um there's this guy uh tony
lopez and he's still fighting yeah
he's tough as [ __ ] so we used to train
together you guys do wheat guy is he
really uh amazing man
iron worker ever is he a darn worker
king of the cage alumni because he's
strong for his size he looks like the
dude from um
like i remember looking at him
there's gotta to be someone from
apocalypse 100 so first i would always
[ __ ] with tony and go you know what tony
he's like what i go you're the reasons
why the aztecs are dead like you took
them out
you just were like ah i'm sick of this
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna cement my
legacy so that everybody's uh
airbrushing me on their [ __ ] low
rider [ __ ] dude yeah no tony lopez
he's sick seeing his face after him and
joey beltran fought each other was like
what uh
you know what he couldn't give two shits
man he's and you know he's such a
beautiful
dude a hard noise like iron worker blue
collar sweet guy with a karate
background really oh he's got a great
sidekick he's i love tony lopez um so he
was also the king of the cage champ for
a long time too wasn't he which is like
a two
yeah like all over the place like no i'm
the columbus king of the cage champ now
i'm the i'm the worster mask king of the
cage champ you know how it goes
you fought beltran right yeah yeah oh
and belton's a great guy by the way here
he even probably knows who terry treble
[ __ ] is i'm talking about the promoter
of king of the cage but
we got barbosa here he's you know bryce
mitchell a pure grappler now bryce
mitchell the interesting thing is he's
been we're watching this right and
mitchell is getting barbosas back to the
wall
yeah because barbados barboza going
backwards usually struggles you can't
let him take oh my gosh yeah couldn't
couldn't couldn't he made that any more
perfect now he's under the butt that
show mitchell's gonna be a double if oh
i see
mitchell
technically yeah he's been the headline
though he's in the headlines lately
because he has some you know um
opinions on
um a lot of certain stuff a lot of stuff
yeah a lot of stuff
or a difference give me an example chin
of the ukraine stuff for sure oh what
was it what do you say about ukraine
enough stuff like it was planned or some
[ __ ] yeah so it's more it's like
conspiracy conspiracy more of a
conspiracy that right but he's right
about a lot of stuff too i think i agree
but then some stuff is a broken cloth
yeah you create a tragedy period like
there's russians or ukrainians it's
being put in the middle of [ __ ]
geopolitics that have been actually that
didn't happen yesterday that have been
happening for at least the last 10 years
if not longer and it's trash and
you know i've got many beautiful russian
people that i know that i love a lot i
i'm sure i've met many ukrainians that
are also awesome uh i don't like to see
these innocents and these lives and
these you know ukrainian ukraine has its
own
argument for its own sovereignty and
everything it joins the church it
[ __ ] sucks yeah and it's crazy it's
happening on 22. it's crazy like i
clicked oh this is this video
well and you know
it's not like things haven't happened in
europe i guess there have been
skirmishes in ukraine there was
obviously the whole crimean thing but
before that you had the uh the balkan
wars yeah they've had like as recently
as 2014. it's not like this i guess to
americans it's new but if you know the
history of it like this has been an
ongoing type of you know animosity for
quite some time it's true and
it sucks it's just terrible i clicked on
this video today i don't know why but uh
it was russian soldiers shooting down
innocent ukrainian civilians well the
one thing i watch
whatever propaganda we're getting right
now oh dude don't buy into it because we
just there's something that's fog of war
like we really can't truly know what's
going on there's no way that's the worst
thing there's no way to know what's
really happening in the world because
everything is such a propaganda machine
well there's a lot of way to find
there's a lot of fake news it's
something of course it is but under war
it's a necessity to use fake news if you
if you want to you know give a cloak
wheel turn there's also no better better
fake news in russia
yeah we're way better
we are the supreme kings of whatever you
want to call fake news but but but at
the end of the day whether it be us or
anyone it could be [ __ ] tim buck too
sure
as soon as you're in the middle of
conflict you want to control and put out
the kind of uh narrative that you think
is going to best serve you and that
is
that's that's just
i think in russia they banned uh they
took him a long time
they banned bbc even yes because they
don't want the narrative getting out
because
for the long you know it's been going
like 10 days now the first five is all
about russia's not doing well there's
like the ghost experience yeah and all
this stuff and it's like well that's not
real this isn't real that's not real and
i you know as far as i can understand
russia's pushing quickly into ukraine
but what they're doing is they're
they're they push in they get resistance
then they back off and they surround the
cities yes because it looks to me that
they're trying to
capture ukraine to some degree maybe
institute a puppet government and not
demolish it i don't think they want to
demolish you all right so i was so did
you see that thing about um about
biochemical laboratories that america
funds yeah you see this thing and i
haven't but
they've done russia and ukraine they do
them all over the world
those got blown up first
did you see that thing yeah that's what
i i don't know i don't know where it's
part i have no idea what's legit and
what's not but like there's a good news
by the way too thank you sir there's a
good josh barnett approval i'll [ __ ]
take it man yeah we just got
distribution uh 30 cities i'm on tour uh
next thursday friday saturday night by
the way
we'll get into this
so because
well not so much you
tyrol
but but people will will bring you up to
me but in a confrontational sense
with you and me but [ __ ] people are
yeah and so i'm always like i got
nothing more like man yeah and i say the
same thing and they're like really i go
why would i he's never said
a single bad word to me he's always been
super [ __ ] kind in fact i had a yell
at a girl i knew because she [ __ ]
kicked you for no reason one time when
we were at this uh
uh this like
this uh this i remember i remember at
the the um
um
um [ __ ] what's his face is uh ford um
why am i my blanket on this uh willard
ford's like opening ceremony thing for
his place that he was doing that's right
and i'm leaving and i'm i've got this
person in my arms being goofy
and you come by like hey we'll see you
later and she just like [ __ ] kicks
you out of nowhere and you're just like
hahaha yeah yeah i was like
seriously and i'm like why the [ __ ] you
kicking people like brandon shaw didn't
ask you to just like [ __ ]
opening of a
come on
and uh but people are like oh what this
that and the other like
why do i have to have a problem with
this guy like are you [ __ ] kidding me
like he's always been cool he's [ __ ]
overrated man yeah smoker's over right
now wait but my whole whiskey is smoke
no no no
you know oh you know oh the dagger what
what were the what where what was the
the bryce tweets though chin did you get
those so i looked pretty
[Music]
yeah i mean we don't have much for
journalism anymore but all right
with an undefeated record okay yeah uh
fighting is all right that doesn't say
anything hold on it says nothing he had
a slick take down i want to talk about
things that are polite i think you're
political i want to do a respectful
manner not to make people other people
think that they're stupid i want to
share my beliefs and hear other people's
beliefs this is all good so far and
maybe their beliefs can sway mine a
little bit maybe not also good maybe i
can out debate them this is all good
because this fight [ __ ] is so minuscule
in life you think yes it's great for me
in a small circle of people that i can
help but this [ __ ] is so minuscule this
is also true yeah you have people out
there being oppressed by governments we
fall into that category believe it or
not if you want me to get real political
the federal reserve is a corrupt
institution
there i went out there and said it these
people control our dollar brother and we
didn't vote for them think about it you
got 13 board members well i mean he's
telling the truth yeah he's not wrong
how corrupted
no we don't yeah i don't have a problem
we don't we don't vote for that for me
to actually be able to talk about
something greater than fighting is more
purposeful than anything i could talk
about related to fighting now by the way
most folks that are political activists
would say this is the proper slant
correct except if they don't like what
he's saying then it's that he's the
enemy but he's he's a hardcore what does
he say about ukraine i don't know i
might have been conflating because just
all that
was like
so yeah so mike our guy well he's
definitely the anti-back stuff he's
drowning
telling him about uh ukraine right now
well he's grounded and he's talking
about you know barbosa some of the uh
that goes to ukraine the grocery kiev
stuff is is was actually a video game
yeah and then you know no the snake
island guys aren't dead yeah yeah or
he's like i think you'd be doing a lot
better if you didn't get boosted
yeah i didn't see him open up barbosa it
must be another huh
yeah now barbarossa's you know trying to
work a butterfly which is good but just
having you know oh good nice wizard get
up
start hustling off the cage now you see
the main thing about it is you got to
hustle your feet now he's in danger of
getting his back taken he stopped to
take a breath
yeah you got to hustle your feet on the
wall yeah that's right it's one thing to
stop the takedown initial but if you're
not moving your feet you're not
separating their head from their hands
the closer their head are to their hands
the stronger their grip is i try to lift
anything like this yeah good luck yeah
yeah
awesome except for except for you
material you lift a lot of things this
way you're like oh it smells like dirty
diapers yeah you probably do that
now bryce mitchell is one of the only
ufc fighters who's not champion to get
his own signature shorts oh because
camouflage
yeah
he has a good personality too you know
what's funny is so i have victor henry
in the ufc now and it's been a long time
hell yeah and uh you know he had like
significant strikes for a debuter and
uh
victor 35 one of his dudes okay and uh
and he's got he's got a world title in
japan with deep he's got a world title
from uh lxf out here he's he is a stud
he was twenty and five when i got him in
there
and uh any any it's a lit up a beautiful
dude he's a really good kid um
victor victor henry
barcelos who is pedro hizzo's protege so
it was me and pedro
with our little students
and i met haoni in brazil training with
pedro and master um
um um
haberta leitao senior rest in peace
and
i'm like i [ __ ] met you way back when
didn't he's like yeah no i did and i
remember them telling me about you and
they're for real like regardless of the
loss howney is a stud yeah howie is a
[ __ ] killer and that was his first
fight in the ufc that was victor's first
fight they threw him to them and uh and
he comes out on top right unanimous
decision but um
uh and victor didn't go to the ground
nope no it didn't even yeah well the
whole point of this fight was to
actually keep it on the feet and pick
away at him pick away at him pick away
him trying to take away his conditioning
yeah
stab his bodies
and then the jab started working so well
we just you know we cut them up busting
them up and and it's you know how any
too is
his benefit it's just tough as nails and
you can't can't sleep on that guy in any
way you make a mistake that dudes so
you're just you're still pretty active
working with guys coaching guys i'm
sparring in the gym i'm sure you still
spar yeah yeah i love it do you really
yeah i see no signs of ct your
vocabulary your recall in history i
think you're good man
so far yeah we'll see i'll figure out
some other way to [ __ ] it up i guess
you know what i was thinking about i was
thinking about today
i don't know why this is so random i was
thinking what's fedor think about you
know with the russia [ __ ] like i was
gonna say
about facebook
you never got a fedora fight like that
wasn't there there was somebody salty
about it but yeah yeah yeah we were
supposed to find an affliction but that
boy that turned into a [ __ ] show yeah i
thought it was gonna be a bellator thing
too possibly but like weren't you i i
put myself out there and they're like no
no yeah
well we know why yeah
i'd we i could we kind of don't make it
maybe i'm not gonna i'm not gonna put
anything on anyone and and
to be honest he didn't he didn't have to
fight me he didn't owe it to me
no if i if i'm fedor and i'm his team as
much as i love fedor and you know have
him in high regards my last fight in
russia where the hell it was isn't gonna
be against josh barnett and i was like
yeah i'll fight him in russia i don't
care it made i thought i thought it was
a shoe i thought it was a shoe and deal
i'm like oh two legends uh tim
johnson tim johnson yeah who's not that
what is that he knocked out uh a killer
wrestler
who's that um
oh what's happening
tyrell
that's jayla
yeah yeah chelsea's boy you know he's
whose boy he really is
todd and trevor lally
people you have no idea they're
old-school matt hume students that i
used to train with oh little redheaded
irish [ __ ] and i love them but but yeah
um and terrell is is fantastic i train
um
tony nelson she's not looking to get
into fighting but you know he's uh
he was fourth on the olympic ladder he's
allowed one of the last guys to beat um
gable stevenson oh super simpson yeah
really yeah i just thought with that
fedor fight his last fight and i saw the
names i think people were kind of upset
with the timothy johnson they were but
you know what there's no
johnson but i was thinking jds was out
there you were you would be the number
one pick jds you also overeem all three
of you i'm older
yeah at fedor and we it's it's even i
mean
it is what it is and it's fine and i'm
actually glad to see him get that win i
even thought matt uh the other name was
in there was that you
uh
overeem jds and then mitrionic because
he's talked about he wants that fight
back he always says that every chance he
gets so he says i gotta have that fight
back drop him took him out with jab
yeah a little bit of baby hook
a little maybe a little check cookie
something it was just a distance render
little rangefinder i had no expectations
to drop them um he's just taking too
many shots you know your chin is your
chin until it isn't mm-hmm and that's no
one can get around that yeah yeah
the rock because he could just eat shots
like nobody's business and then the day
came that he couldn't take him anymore
that's just what it was even mark hunt
who had a granite chin then finally roy
nelson you know
well rightly
when they're ready
no he knocked out roy yeah he knocked
him out walked off yeah
hey chin bring up marco no who who
walked off uh santos talked about with
the spinning uh spinning heel kicking
right
there was that yeah but
right and also him and him
just killed each other and you're like
well both of you are supposed to you
know bigfoot's not supposed to happen
anymore
by the way i couldn't believe how many
shots [ __ ]
uh
big country took
jeez i'm like how how are you not going
down by now i've sucked you up all night
long no i know i got you on on wobbly
street but i couldn't get you to talk
about when you when you fought
nelson yeah dude such a badass fight i'm
thinking of over him knocked him out
with that knee oh grandpa was a [ __ ]
knee yeah
and derek lewis
no no he won't beat them
then he lost his blades okay that makes
sense who's kept taking him down
that makes sense
justin willis
justin's tough he's a gamer
he's a grinder yeah i was uh referring
to that also over him knee which was you
know i was the first like horrible
knockout for him that was tough man
knocked him out stipe was more of a
barrage by the way stipe
i think stipe
has declined so
rapidly he's just yes
when he fought cormier it's like where's
the jab where is this where are you
standing in front of the first time the
first time
the first time he loses the core man
like why did you let the wrestler suck
you up and knock you out right and then
the second time
he figures it out and starts body
shotting them and cormier won't stop the
liver shot and he takes them out but i
go but you took on all all kinds of
unnecessary punishment
you can't keep doing that then of course
he fights nagano again against it's like
come on man
now now they're they're thinking it's
going to be uh steve
jones
he's honest
by the way i think john jones they're
thinking it's debate john jones next
when is when does he get the ankle
bracelet off
i think he's going to fight with the
ankle bracelet did you see that i think
he's going to throw head kicks with the
ankle bracelet
you see some triple a's
across the across the ring yeah do that
that video of wow
probably something like that dude yeah
he yeah yeah he was arrested
granted those domestic violence charges
you hear the kid asking security i mean
look it's horrible but we all know that
women can push our buttons to the most
degree but you don't [ __ ] sacrifice
hold on well first of all
as far as i know like no matter what he
has for two years no no you just like
you know what i'm gonna leave the house
you're also going to follow me and keep
[ __ ] with me the whole time i'm
leaving the home but
i'm not going to [ __ ] touch you
especially if you're the toughest man on
the planet yeah you know right you just
can't do that man only sean connery can
yeah there you go my little schmuck yeah
and like there were a bunch of cops
around him and he's like he's like i
didn't do anything i didn't do anything
and then they they were like listen you
gotta go sit in the back of the car he
starts hopping up and down and then head
butts to [ __ ] say he hates him and
he's like i challenge the five of you
yeah he's like the five you come get
this yeah start calling uh the cops are
like he's no better yeah
that's not gonna happen hi i'm i'm joe
smith i'm here to get a pension yeah and
not have some [ __ ] jacked up pissed
off best in the world fighter yeah kick
the [ __ ] out of me muscle joe smith with
a taser yeah so it's like i'm not going
to grab it it's not going to go when i
get a baton right here too buddy
and a part of me is i feel like matt
mitrione
uses a taser as a sex toy that's what i
thought that was a really good chance
that's been in my bedroom before there's
a good chance that's in my bedroom yeah
i'll throw that out but there's a lot
you know there is a toy by the way that
has multiple tips that's all about like
static electricity and shocking i'm out
my dick does not agree with that i mean
i'm not into it yeah unless i'm using it
for sure
if i'm not getting [ __ ] like rubbed
on the carpet and shocked by yeah
that's ryan clark we're we're rookies
together
he's a fight fan but he was a uh
pittsburgh steeler girl
goatees
we were both undrafted free agents with
the giants yeah and from from illinois
you get drafted why did i why did i not
uh because you're all big ten yeah yeah
how did you do were you were you d
tackle
tackle yeah
and i ran off i ran a 481 at 295. nuts
um
you your chubby face at 295
oh my [ __ ] my rookie year i was so fat
hold up chance
i've seen this guy what a beautiful baby
boy
he's thick yeah um like i i think he
drafted probably because i was yeah i
was a problem he was a big fan
of nfl giants
nfl giants rookie pick yeah oh you'll
see it his face is
it's uh good to see you man you look
love you joe
yeah joe's back yeah really you can't do
that hey by the way i was 71 in high
school were you really yes i was you
know who else was santana datsun really
talking about tampa earlier weren't we
too yeah yeah
keep going it'll go it'll come up here
there's greg hardy everywhere
oh
that's okay oh my god it's brown eyed
it's all mma
that's [ __ ] awesome i'm so proud
um i don't see where it is now yeah it's
all in me yeah it is all my my nfl life
is all done now huh
yeah it's all done it's not there
anymore oops
that was us do you see us down there
facebook
yeah that picture with you with the
vikings it's like that's too that's too
nice yeah it's like no this is my this
goes on my myspace profile he did look
like it was on your friend's third long
hair
practice oh look at him y'all smiley and
oh i'm friendly as i run these bleachers
right trying to do a little something
you know ain't it funny like when you
look at pictures from how long ago that
was man oh like i'm hell you how long
you been in the fight game man
70 years yeah it seems like it um
my first fight was at 19 years old um
so you're 25 years yeah good god brother
you see that man good math
who says common core doesn't help
[Laughter]
i wonder what kind of wild [ __ ] he's
saying right now
right now he's probably going i want to
know is it the greys and the lizardmen
yeah combined and they the earth decided
that they're going to take ukraine
because they're going to use those
nuclear reactors to launch your
spaceships there's this flat i'm out and
slows the mic on the ground
and eddie somewhere smiles yeah eddie's
like excellent
pays him five thousand dollars for a
bonus uh but anyways uh listen if you're
looking for uh the best stuff and below
the waist hygiene you gotta hit up my
friends at manscape that's right they're
turning men's shower dreams into their
favorite routine with the all-new ultra
premium collection this is an all-in-one
hygiene skin and hair bundle it's
designed to upgrade the every man's
shower routine from head to frickin toe
your skin your hair your balls deserve
this save by michael irvin would buy it
he'd definitely buy it that guy would
buy it too uh save big by going to
manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping with the code cfc step one
lather
clone infused ultra premium body wash
step two it's a hair care time apply the
two in one shampoo
uh step four you have tattoos or dry
skin cool let's hit your skin with some
hydrating body moisturizer spray
oh i like how the camera
oh that's um oh god he used to date
carol g anyways the elite trimmer is
designed to trim here on loose skins
this is a all new bundle change your
life and want all the viewers and
listeners of cowboys fight club to live
their best lives man get 20 percent off
and free shipping with the code cfc
manscape.com this is 2020 and free dude
and free shipping
that's the code cfc at manscape.com it's
time to get wet and clean with the new
manscape shower routine so with these
clippers right
thomas
you know what it's basically like those
little those little deals for taking
pills off of sweaters yeah like that
yeah it's got the guard on it so i'm
saying so five years
on my coin purse like i'm not gonna get
like the little like little cats on my
nuts
dude i'll put it on my face yeah i'll be
honest with you yeah i'll do both yeah
you know what it's straight up nuts
that's my face that's the face facing
nuts that's how it goes i don't care i
mean but there's a i don't know there's
a light on this one though the stuff in
the face is going to double those blades
quicker than your little little rosy
rosy reds down below yeah you're right
that's the way it goes yeah that's the
worst like once you like you shave your
junk and then like you start smashing us
on your tastes like burning yeah
[Laughter]
my kids are like dad did you really just
say chlamydia
i could have called it the clap yeah you
know that's how it goes sometimes
yeah lovely times
josh what do you think what do you think
happens with uh francis and ghana are
you aware of what's going on with him so
he so he's an ambulance champ right he's
now he's trying to mcgregor this and you
know when i talk about mcgregor
going back to something um i say the the
the most beneficial thing about conor
was him fighting
the contractual elements so he could go
out and box
that opened up a lot of doors for us
potentially um and the boxing model pays
way better than the ufc model not
because
it's not just about the amount of money
that's available it actually is
they're leveraging their earning
potential against ticket sales pay value
sales in a way that the ufc generally it
doesn't allow it's not that the money
doesn't exist it's just that the fighter
in the boxing model is able to access it
but it's also two different models
though right because
you have two fighters who make the line
share the money and the rest card gets
paid well trust me you'll see it's top
to bottom
you know so like when the argument is
ufc fighters need to be paid more i'm
like actually the starting off guys are
making great money for what they're
doing and i would say my argument is
right the ufc probably spends more money
on lower level fighters than the mon
than those fighters ever bring the ufc
100 for sure and so it's not all bad no
now i'm not a fan of the ufc contract
scenario but they didn't create it
there's basically it's a wwe contract
which i would know
because i manage athletes in wwe also oh
you do so it's it's a is it a similar
contract well somewhat actually the
wwe's one a little better to be honest
interesting but um it's it's a
totalizing contract and that's the the
argument against it totalizing meaning
it's a monopoly well no not that it's a
monopoly it's just that the
one unless you have enough leverage to
create any bargaining posture there's
not much you can do about it number two
uh it covers every aspect of of
compensation now
in some sense it has you could say it's
improved or it's gotten worse and the
fact they've got what's called a 360
deal which also includes merchandising
and things like that yeah
but
the main thing about it is that why
people will complain about some guy
making x amount of money going from like
like let's say mcgregor going from to
this to the boxing
you have to understand one he didn't
just box joe schmoe he boxed the most
aggressive yeah he boxed floyd
mayweather so of course it's a different
scenario but also remember the ufc was
in cahoots with that they were a
business partner right mcgregor and he
didn't go off on his own that's also
somewhat acceptable in my opinion right
so if if the ufc is going to get a five
or ten percent cut on the end of that
yeah okay then you'll lease them out
and i think they deserve it they could
especially if they're promoting the bout
as well because
when
their athlete goes and competes
somewhere else it's still an
advertisement for them yep like it makes
it's making everybody and that's why i
really hope francis comes to terms with
ufc because he's going to get that fury
fight i'm telling he's going to get that
fear he's going to get killed
it's tough fight for him i think fear is
the best i mean his hands are heavy is
all [ __ ]
but fury is going to be out of the way
yeah
deante wilder's hands were heavy
right he's like a right-hand
maniac and yet couldn't couldn't really
get it going he couldn't touch him
really except for that first right but
so i think i want francis to sign by the
way it's super [ __ ] impressive that
you got to uh go out there and call
showtime boxing before i was like
part of me was like god damn it shot
[ __ ] i would have loved this
yeah you know oh and and by the way back
to when uh how i was talking about
people always trying to put us against
each other
you [ __ ] gone up on stage and then
stand up yeah yeah i don't have the guts
to do that oh dude and people can like
run their mouth whatever they want big
audiences like not like little kids but
whether whether you get a chance to
complain or to cheer rah-rah-rah yeah
you [ __ ] went up there yeah yeah i've
never done it yeah and so part of me is
like
you can say whatever you want about
whether you think he's funny or not yeah
uh
i gotta talk [ __ ] i can't say [ __ ]
dick all right yeah cause that dude's
balls are bigger than mine
in this area no no i don't have i don't
have the courage i i the first time i
ever went on stage to do anything other
than like fight or present or like do um
commentary or anything of that nature
was my buddy carl sanders who's the
main dude behind this band called nile
this death metal band he literally calls
me out in the middle of the audience
spotlights me and says oh he's going to
come up and sing black seeds avengers
with us
okay so they [ __ ] grab me before the
song is going to go on
i'm like i'm losing my [ __ ] i'm getting
sweaty as [ __ ] my heart's going crazy
the biggest fights in the world and i'm
thinking oh my god my throat's gonna
close up and i'm not gonna be able to
say anything right like i'm just gonna
get up there and squeak and everyone's
gonna like what the [ __ ] why is he here
and and i tell carl afterwards i go that
was one of the most [ __ ]
nerve-wracking moments in my entire life
he goes what you go out there and fight
grown ass men i go that's
not the same thing
how'd you do though
okay the first time the second time i
[ __ ] killed it yeah but the first
time was like oh my god
this is gonna be uh watch my fly will
open my dick will pop out at its worst
moment it's all like turtling and it's
gonna be everything you've ever dreaded
in your entire life your dick's never
been so small
wrapped up into one little dish
one little nice package yeah and so
people will say [ __ ] i'm like brendan
schaub's got more balls than me for sure
because the motherfucker's gone up there
and called [ __ ] he did stand up and
went up there and killed died didn't
matter he [ __ ] did it and on
he did that but also like went on stage
with like with like
coco and and and calendar you had to
follow yeah like
guys [ __ ] names you know like yeah
like last night
monsters
you know what that's awesome i've said
the
yeah i've always loved you man
from a distance even though people think
we hate each other that's all right at
least seven inches away is fine
um
now this fight was supposed to be dos
angelos versus fazeev
fazeev tess is hot for kovid oh
he's out he's okay yeah he's okay we
found out on ariel's show found out live
on youtube oh really yeah yeah
oh i got to get back and i got to bring
some mccorkle love into here at some
point [ __ ] love that oh sean mccorkle
you are a [ __ ] brilliant little piece
of [ __ ] dude his he's so witty it's like
he lives out in the middle of nowhere in
indiana i think he has like 20 uber
drivers
[Laughter]
i don't even know i talk to him every
once in a while like i'll hit him up
yeah that [ __ ] will always land
on his feet oh for sure dude like and
he's like he's like genuinely like a
concerned person like he like cares
about yes like and like i think he feels
like the fight game like really
abandoned him and kind of left him
behind which i know i didn't appreciate
any of the nuance about sean and then
the deeper level of who he was as a
person he didn't give a [ __ ] the fight
fight game is very black and white of
course it's very black and white i mean
all professional sports is the nfl yeah
you got you got away more black and
white over the time yeah more black and
white over time yeah because because
quirky came around at the time they
wanted to have personalities and like
and for some reason more of a
personality
[ __ ] dude he's so money like and the
stuff he would say would be just golden
like like i remember we were doing like
the metro minute and then it started
turning into the mccorkle material yes
and i was like dude i can't have you on
i can't compete with you dude like he's
so good and like he would have these
jokes that i would never have the balls
why doesn't he do something with it um i
think that good question actually um you
know i think that he would be he's
always talking about hey let's do some
writing let's write some stuff and like
you go on stage and like do whatever he
wants me to be the does he have stage
fright
um i think he's got really bad back
issues man bad but you just have to
stick he could sit like mark
um he could sit like
i'm telling you like he is he is
probably one of the wittiest people i've
ever heard
and he's [ __ ] i wrote this [ __ ]
in seattle coming up like hey if you
want me to help you set up a [ __ ] uh
an after party for this i know i have
all these connections i'll do this and
later on in life he goes yeah
i didn't know that that was really you i
thought it was just some [ __ ] and i
just ignored it and i'm like
well but if you want to try stem i'd
give them gigs in indiana well i always
know all the too i go like no one wants
to be me trust me it's only going to be
like no one's trying to pretend to be
josh barnett they're like nah not
[ __ ] interested there's way better
[ __ ]
there's way better uh playoffs than that
he um
he's uh so so you know uh makachev asked
to
take this fight in short notice because
he just uh beat up bobby and bobby green
and then i guess the ufc offered to him
then he he didn't take it no way yeah so
then we
dana white was like he has to fight
garyus next because he turns yeah that's
a great way to get in the
in the [ __ ] house real quick
if you put it out there oh wow because
he's just getting on his back right away
he's gonna be the next teleporter ah
nice dosagnos showing that experience
dude
like he fell off a little bit and all of
a sudden just dude he's fought probably
the toughest schedule as far as uh
competition goes he's fine
a nice little foot sweep with a helper
pushing into him or you take all that
energy driving under the fence nice
little foot sweep would have put moykano
potentially dude i love dos angels he's
the only guy when i fought nogara in
brazil he's the only brazilian that
would take me to certain spots where
they wouldn't poison my food fought no
garrett in brazil yeah dude wait till
you're i wanted a rematch with that guy
so bad you beat him right once yeah and
then they gave him what i would call a
gimme decision the second time what was
that at japan yeah i really feel like it
was like uh that's no that dude didn't
beat me that time but you know what my
my argument is always this
and it's to my fighters too if i don't
finish you then whatever happens
out of my hands
so whether it be bad good neutral
yep nothing i didn't do my job by taking
them out yeah
there's a story i don't know if it's oh
[ __ ] that could have been oh that wasn't
hurt
there's a story that i don't know
brendan wants to say on air or not about
a sponsorship that came about when he
fought noguera in in brazil oh no i'll
tell the story i had to be acai oh dude
this [ __ ] was banana i did have boney
eyes it's either either
bell for his dad it's either it's gonna
be acai's or brothels it's either yeah
i wish it was a brothel no it was uh
good shot
oh nice apparently nogueira is tied to
this soccer team out there they call it
football i guess but we call it soccer
he's tied the soccer game so i was the
favorite going in the fight and the
night before the fight my amal easton
who's uh fluent in portuguese this this
this guy yeah
yeah he's who i get my black belt from
um
these businessman sat down with them in
portuguese
like i don't speak portuguese clearly
and then uh mall goes okay they're gonna
give you i think it's 50 or 80 grand in
cash and when you knock no gear out you
got to put on this jersey and it's the
rival team's jersey i go cool give me
the jersey so they give me the you said
cool in brazil yeah say cool give me the
jersey okay patreon knows
yeah trust me so friday night before the
fight i'm in my uh hotel room in brazil
in rio and uh these two henchmen like
you know dark arts dudes
come to the room
they type in the buddies of mine yeah
probably you probably know him he
probably like locked him
he they typed in the code put the money
in and then told my coach was like when
he wins we'll call and give you the code
if he loses we're gonna come get the
money so they put like 80 grand cash in
the thing so i'm like sweet that's my
money man i'm gonna destroy this dude
obviously didn't go that way i'm all
concussed by my [ __ ] hotel room after
the fight my dad's in there these two
mafia henchmen knock on door goes sorry
for your loss
take the cash
and then they said something i'm like
what they say goes they said you could
keep the jersey
okay cool cool yeah right right on yeah
yeah all right thanks for the jersey
i think my dad framed the joke by the
way brendan welcome to the real fight
world yeah right yes this is the one i
grew up this is the one i grew up in
those are pride days a little bit for
you yeah
sitting
at the top of a in a private room at the
top of this building in tokyo in a
chinese restaurant
completely surrounded by yakuza and
other officials
and being told oh
you and bob the church the the your
outfits at the the weigh-ins are the
press conferences that's unacceptable
you look you look sloppy we're going to
take you out you got to take them out to
go get suits
okay i'm assuming bob sapp you're
looking at getting that guy's suit oh no
oh they get there
i'm sure
suckers big and tall in tokyo i mean the
biggest and tall yeah they they suit up
sumos oh and so me and bob go they build
him a suit from scratch they give me
they set me up in off the off the rack
versace's yeah
tailor us up yeah
and so when we come back to our next
part uh our next uh press conferences we
look [ __ ] legit right and
rampage talked about they would give
them a brief case of cash all the time
just get leave a briefcase and they'd be
like all right thank you could happen
that's gonna happen yeah you know what's
interesting is none of the pride guys
really talk about it yeah it's like this
pride was like great it's like this
fight club like you know like we between
the three of us we have all kinds of
[ __ ] in our lives that we're just like
nah keep it to the vest it's not for
public consumption it's not the way it's
been meant to be yeah and that's just it
and
look the carnival roots of professional
fighting wrestling all these things
they're still there yeah and
i've never had a bad experience dealing
with the underside of these things
because they generally
have a lot of high respect for
fighters especially ones
yeah you know gumption yeah and and will
it is what it is i'm not trying to get
involved in that kind of stuff i'm not
trying to be
like some part of the underworld but no
so i someone sent me this uh documentary
like you got to talk about someone's
show you got to highlight this and it
was into the the promoter for like fury
and and connor and till like this guy
who had this and you're thinking no i
don't yes
like this you know mafia background like
oh oh no i want no part of this dude
this isn't what i do because i'm not
changing whether you talk about it or
not like this isn't my [ __ ] deal i
like these guys i'm out yeah i want
nothing to do so last time we came up
here i was during the super bowl and we
ended up uh going out after after the
show
and we ended up running with this uh
really connected dude in
an asian mob
and um did you guys go out with brian
and you were you shilling this is this
is after this is after brian split okay
so like we went to like some some joint
had a couple beers with brian um i think
he had a glass of chardonnay yes
that sounds about right yeah um and so
so we so uh that split off and then we
ended up at this club with this asian
mob and these dudes are all all inked up
like full like to their jawline their
skulls are tattooed um everything across
the board style yeah for sure oh it's
like my opponent martine yeah
for sure um and then so we get we get
the spot the club closes i don't know
two o'clock three o'clock something like
that and then we end up at this um after
hours karaoke bar that was just popping
through and it was like it was just i
have an idea where this is do you really
was jumping so hard and i was like
you guys are out all night oh dude
there's a karaoke bar it was a go i left
this izakaya in this mall yeah
to go to the bathroom you had to go
outside yeah i'm like why are there all
these [ __ ] women in like hoochie
outfits just walking around this place
this is weird
yeah
uh karaoke spot that has private rooms
yeah there's giants
posted up signs everywhere like no
prostitution and i've seen these girls
coming in and out and i go
we might have been in the same spot
i don't think anyone reads english
he's really prostitute heavy yeah he
seems really prostituted yeah yeah he
might have been in the same spot so
check this out i got a story for you
about about the the we were in cancun it
was my buddy's uh 40th birthday party he
had us come down it was like i think
four of us were down there five of us
and we went down there and um and the
first night we're walking around in this
club and uh he picks up a couple of
different hookers
this is in cancun you must be pretty
strong to do that so i do yeah he's a
massive dude so he picks up a couple of
hookers right and he's like carrying him
on his shoulders and he's walking out
you know blah blah blah and um so he
goes in there and he they smash whatever
and then the next morning he calls up
the credit card company and he cancels
his credit card and he's like hey it got
stolen i didn't do this it was like four
g's or something like that and and and
night like for parties
did he buy two tijuana
four geez and tijuana so yeah this is
the credit card
so that's like manscape so we're so
we're there you know this is like
landscape 5.0 whatever so we're supposed
to be there for four days right
so the second day
he does the same damn thing again again
and so the third night i was like dude i
can't be around you you're gonna get
shot i cannot because the cartel runs
out yeah uh-huh so the third day he's a
a big dude he does not does not blend in
any crowd
and so we're going out there and like
and all of a sudden this really fly
chick comes up and she's like hey big
fella hey blah blah once you come over
here we're going to be part of that's
like day you think some random really
pretty chick walks up to you and brings
you like tells you to go to some spot
for no reason like you're going to get
that that's
i'm not going with you man like
absolutely if you guys go that's your
fault i'm not in that
dude they got locked in a room they got
locked in a room for like 36 hours he
deserves it and they were deserved
they had to have like 40 people up to
wire money by the way plus by the way
like ripping off ripping off a stripper
is [ __ ] low agree oh dude
actual denver aurora you seem like an
arvada guy oh okay i'll take that but i
see what you're saying there
he's like thanks for the backhand the
cobbles
no you're not coming back on my show no
no aurora you're like oh i'm just like
uh
[ __ ] chili's and yeah
my ladies from evergreen oh really uh
evergreen snipes man uh even never been
right next to lilton and where uh lauren
was coaching uh
lauren well now lauren's the strength
coach for the broncos yeah evergreen is
next to
[ __ ] uh
i can't recall there's like another it's
like 7 400 elevation uh evergreen
colorado chin can you bring it on a map
um
it's a five-round fight because uh
dosanos is a stud but they were it was
originally planned for a five-round
fight before uh
fighting it wasn't the main thing i know
but it's supposed to be on a fight
honestly right now
who got cancelled twice yeah he got
canceled he's been such a driver's seat
this whole fight oh for sure he's been
he's been he's been doing a hell of a
people really there's that double wrist
lock you'll know that material let me
see the map chin where where's it at on
the map on the maps yeah evergreen
that looks oh that's not maybe that's
not it
uh no those are like pictures scroll
down tin
uh yeah go click on that one it looks
like we're gonna be able to see it
evergreen
i mean it's right outside denver about
30 or 40 minutes yeah it's beautiful
um right in the mountains there's a
[ __ ] lake out there
you ever think about leaving l.a oh yeah
i want to go back to washington
and also i want to split time between
evergreen and washington for me to look
after my mom
and look after her mom that's cool you
know to me it's very important that you
you respect and you take care of your
elders because they did so much for you
when you weren't capable i agree so do
it do the same when they get in their
elder years and look after all these
things you know i'm really you do you do
a great job about your parents like you
involve your parents alive like like you
become successful and it's it's never
been you've you've
become
less
you become more humble the more
successful you've become
which is a very unique situation i think
a stand-up stand up so hard to do and
like my mom i flew in on yesterday and
she came here today came to the studio
and she started crying yeah she's like
look at all you've bailed and started
crying she's like and she's never told
me this oh yeah part of this she's like
i can't imagine the fact that i said
well let's relax we're only at 130 000
subscribers yeah you you get you get
humble
by realizing how much effort it takes to
get to this point and how quickly it
could be gone it can be gone very fast
but also really good friends that had it
gone just like that correct and also but
stand up so tough like i don't have time
it is tough it's so tough and like my
special's coming out some i had to write
a new hour so it's like it's so
challenging and takes all my effort
as far as like you know i don't listen
to social media unless they say i don't
have time for it i've been i've been
getting barred with people who hate you
yeah from from tweets and stuff i'm like
i'm not paying attention to this [ __ ]
yeah but but it's just like everyone
wants to either love you or hate you but
to me
and i've always explained to my fighters
it's the same thing
loving your body being loved or being
hated is an emotional response don't be
indifferent towards me that's all i care
about you know yeah people don't care
you're [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah exactly
opinion you're screwed i think don't try
to go for a shot huh okay it kind of
looked like that moycano stopped took
his own shot off balanced him but
uh dossagnios is really easy behind his
jab and he's being really patient
notice man it's tough dude
i think that the physique
the low kick is doing doing good for him
but oh he's getting touched a bunch
right now he needs to stay behind the
legs just and then when mike steps up
with the shots yes
go to the takedown you know
i was going to say i think brendan with
you um uh
you've been in two extremely humbling
careers right like fighting like uh
we're talking about connor right yeah
was getting out on uh habib to start and
then he got or nate diaz yeah he was
getting out on nate and then started and
got a little got done i was getting out
on uh ben rothwell and i got cocky i got
taken down right i think i got choked
like i think there's so many things that
our sport
is so
oh oh oh oh oh oh that head kick land
[Music]
yeah might be the end of it now
um anyway so it's all instantly humbling
right and it happens just like that that
um with fighting yeah yes uh but also in
in in in comedy right he's he's on oh
he's bad oh he's he's hurt quite yeah
quite well yeah yeah no he's really
hurting he's gonna jump back into his
guard no he should not that guy's on
autopilot he's letting him right yeah
exactly
but but with with fighting you there's
you get humbled very
um what's physical humble right
physically humble it's also very
important he's here to figure it out
it's hard to figure out if you got
humbled on stage it's not though because
it's pretty black and white because if
when you go on stage they're laughing or
they're not yeah last night to follow
monsters but can you can you figure out
why they're not laughing sometimes
though sometimes it's the rearrangement
of words sometimes it's the topic
sometimes in l.a like why do you want to
even get into stand-up i've always
wanted to do it really like okay my mom
that that's one thing i was telling my
me and my mom are talking about today
like
you know she me and her to watch
saturday night live every saturday and
she was always the one that believed in
me to do stand up so she was like really
the main driver and then you know you
know
coming to la and meeting brian and then
rogan you know pushing me into it so
yeah perfect on your own right because i
remember you like hey i'm thinking about
doing this podcast we're going to call
it this yeah and i was like who's yeah
yeah yeah i met him because i was a
coach on the ultimate fighter and they
brought brian in to make the kids laugh
and then i was i just moved to l.a uh
nate mark brought brian they met once
and he was like hey the kids named our
card
is
fantastic [ __ ] fighter
crazy i watched him
by the way though you know and
not trying to be offensive to the other
dude but
nate mark hart's beating genki pseudo i
believe it is
and then whoever is coaching him at the
time tells him to see some dumb ass [ __ ]
and gets armbard i'm like
are you even here come out mark come on
nate yes and pancakes are you pancras
champ when nate was out there too uh no
well sort of like
so it's funny because didn't they call
him the king of pancrease well
here's the thing so i've been the one
person to be like nate markhart's not
the big king of pancreas he's a weight
class champion of pancreas and they're
like oh he's the seventh time i go
no
he's never been the king of pancreas
because the king of pancreas is an open
weight title everything else is a weight
class title oh
and so i'm i'm the one guy sitting back
being like uh
no yeah no
i'm not trying to diss the dude because
he's [ __ ] sick and i love watching
him fight it's not about that though
it's what i'm like he did not fight open
weight yeah yeah and
you can't be the king of pancreas if
you're not fighting the open weight
title you know you're not fighting boss
rooting not fighting [ __ ] funaki and
suzuki
you're considered the king yeah he was
the king of people yeah he's the
original kid yeah me you don't need boss
and funaki are i think tied with most
defenses as king of pancakes
yeah that's no dude that's dope
you know nate's still fighting yeah
that's true true but you know his win
over tyron woodley was like oh [ __ ] like
mortal kombat
dude yeah it was like champ
nate nate and the thing that'll kill me
about nate is like i watch him and go
you're such a sick grappler too but you
won't [ __ ] employ it
oh he's really sick and he lost one
fight to a carlson gracie guy
i can't remember his name he was he was
tankers no
ifc okay which no one watching this
knows about yeah but uh it was a guy
that was from um
diaz's uh gracie coach oh my god i
remember him
um he was a stockton dude or stockton or
sacramento or from that area so this guy
from the state he was training with nate
and nick and all that this guy beat nate
markhart
in this fight through control metrics
whereas nate's going after submission on
his back and going for everything and
the guy was shutting him down and beat
him
and then after that it's like the
submission aspect of nate just really he
didn't really he wasn't chasing after
himself he got really into boxing he got
really into striking and boxing but the
thing is he's got such a sick ground
game
that you know
incorporating these things all together
and making them blend
to me would have made nate markhart a
ufc champion i agree
and then he talked about you know when
he fought for the title he fought
anderson silva and it was just the
moment it was too big and it was
anderson at his best it's just so hard
to deal with if you can get him on his
back maybe you had a chance but like
jail like chael and also travis luter
yes that's right but um
don't blow your nose you know anderson
at his best is [ __ ] he's going he's
goat stuff you know
what do you think of this youtube stuff
josh you pay attention to like the jake
paul stuff and logan uh
i can appreciate
the benefit that it's giving to other
fighters and the thing that gets left
out of the dialogue is that
um jake paul
is
building up um
amanda serrano yes yeah yeah i go no one
else is you know he's doing a lot for
other people battling dana white where
he's not in business with him so he can
kind of release the hound yeah i mean
there's a few things he said and i'm
like i get where you're going but you're
[ __ ] totally wrong you don't get it
like there's things you're missing
really important key points yes to um
economics that you just don't [ __ ]
understand you know i quit talking about
fighter pay i could i used to be super
out of it but then
you know i guess with experience just
getting older i'm like i don't know what
i don't know their business the thing
about fighters as far as i did a
documentary with bobby razak about about
this stuff and he asked me about the
unions i'm like not a fan i'm not and i
don't support and i go why i go what
look all this stuff is generally built
around like um fighter pay and all the i
go but the real the only people that
really are suffering under fighter pay
are once you make it
it's those are the actual like the main
event semi-main event coleman like those
are the guys
and gals that are the ones who are
actually have the issue yes
everyone at the lower level not at all
taking care of the lord no they're
getting they're paid their worth and
let me tell you the way they took care
of my boy victor
his fights coming up they're giving him
free nutrition meal plans all this stuff
they're [ __ ] doing great stuff for
them that's right i was so like blown
away yeah i stopped hating on them
before because i was like i don't i
don't know you know i don't live in
their house i have no idea what what
their overhead is you know what what it
cost their marketing i don't know
they're over i don't know that stuff
yeah but and i've played i've been on
both ends i promote i've i've been i've
been involved in promoting in the mma
sense i run my own pro wrestling events
i i'm involved in all kinds of stuff on
both ends so i understand where the
costs come in where the margins are and
to just simply say like well ufc makes a
bunch of money so xyz it's like that's
really a stupid way of approaching yeah
it's not as black and white as that no
yeah it isn't so i i literally stopped
going hard on the ufc about it
um
we're talking about grappling nate
markhart
there's
native sick there are two of my favorite
submissions
that i learned from watching videos of
you i never told you about these before
was this one like the the [ __ ] grabs
no i don't think it might be also it's
your teeth i mean it takes a while it
takes a while for that one to come to
effect like when it does it's also
illegal yeah they're debilitated they
get real sleepy real fast um it was um
it was you're
you're in cross bodies you're in side
control yeah cross body on them and um
you you switch to the back side like so
you turn your back to him so you're
facing his legs and you reach through
the inside of his leg hook his leg and
turned into a hip lock and brought it in
and drove your shoulder down into it and
i was like i was like oh my god like
that is such a dope submission because
you did it in some catch tournament yeah
and i was like oh my god that's so dope
and then like so i started trying to hit
him on people right but i realized you
fished on the inside of his ankle versus
the outside because he's strong enough
to kick out if you do the outside of the
ankle but on the inside you're right
he's going into your face i think you're
actually thinking about the reverse
outside toe hold and what i'll do is
i'll reach up and i get the outside of
his in his big toe yeah and i lock my
elbow and drive it into his own hip
sounds awful and then he tries to
straighten it out and he can't yeah and
it just makes it worse for him yes
that's awesome yeah i'll do it it's
incredible it looked it was they dude
like squealed like a pig incredible
and then another one was you were uh you
were crossbody again and um you blocked
his elbow with your right hand
and then you were starting to fish
around and he thought you were going for
a kimura and i think like and you he was
like he was proud of himself because he
was like isolating he was he was
protecting himself from you bringing his
elbow you're able to cross his face so
he thought he was doing a good job but
that just fed into what you wanted to do
then you trapped you trapped his wrist
you made him think about it and you
blocked it and then you put your hand in
his armpit and put him in a neck crank
from that position you know what i'm
talking about uh i think i do yeah oh
dude it was so dope when i watched i was
like i was like oh my god that's why you
sought out josh well it was one of the
like first sayings like but i always
heard about that i knew who josh was and
i was like yeah i mean honestly matt
just literally got my number and just
started hitting me up and i go if you're
this dedicated like yeah absolutely come
out i'll help you anything anyway i
can't what fight did you start working
with josh
[ __ ] i don't remember but like we were
in the ufc yeah yeah i was out there i
was out there for a while like for like
weeks at a time i was out there like i
was staying in a place where i was
renting a room inside of a house of a
family they kicked a kid out of the room
and i was they were sleeping on the
couch and i was like i can't do this
it's really weird man
oh dude i was like
i was trying to do as much as i could to
try to come out and train with him and
he always made time he always made it
like available and like there was like i
never felt
i never felt anybody
so dedicated to hanging on my neck like
i was in spots like i was up against the
wall we were scrapping and um and i knew
that he wanted to get me to the ground
we were doing some stand-up work and it
was full of may
and i was on the wall and like and he
couldn't get me down in the position
and he was on my neck because i'm sure
if he freed his hands if you let go of
my neck he'd be dropped into a single
switch off the double stand heavy on the
nose and dude just stayed on it and i
was like dude he's got to be yeah it was
about like two and a half minutes and
i'm like he's there's he's going to give
up and go to something else right now
how'd you feel oh how's your neck feel
oh bruh that's what he's doing this was
this was mark coleman
front head locking the death out of me
and going like
i'm going to i'm going to steal this
i have a thing with [ __ ] coleman
because i trained him for a fight and
worked with him and cornered him and i
just felt like uh he fought nogara it
was a really short notice yeah and then
he got triangle armbard i'm like goddamn
it but
but coleman by the way incredible
storyteller beautiful human being mark i
[ __ ] love the [ __ ] he's the best yeah
um
but his [ __ ] front headlock was like
get me on the olympics kind of [ __ ]
right oh [ __ ]
and so
i tell mark to this very day and i'll
tell him on twitter i'll tell mom it
doesn't matter i'll tell him to his face
i go [ __ ] you could be in a
wheelchair
if i knock your ass over and i score my
two i'm taking
taking it [ __ ] you cole man i want to
[ __ ] get it i want my take down
against mark coleman i'm gonna to the
end of the days i'm gonna do it and to
your point mark mark can talk man i sat
next to him in a pellet fight oh i can't
tell you who fought on the car he talked
my ear off and i was like dude you and i
looked down his story i know you should
do a podcast he was really you've
literally talked all right story hours
dude he's now you got don fry and dan
severn which is great you got don fry's
like
listen brother this [ __ ] guy over and
then yeah i know what you mean
you know the the persecution of the the
excellence of this it's like [ __ ] dan
how did how did don fry not get cass in
1883 for sure absolutely what's 1883 the
it's the prequel to yellowstone you
probably watch it you don't i don't have
tv
well it's it's great i read books like
an [ __ ] i've just started the
smartest game i've just started reading
right now what are you doing like i'm
probably i'm on my fourth i heard it's
fundamental
what they say i'm on my fourth book this
year but i'm reading um you just got
into books uh yeah yeah uh grisham john
christian you know what's okay i'm in a
john grisham books okay that's what i'm
into there's better books but i'm sure
there are lots of reading you gotta get
your toes on the ground maybe i mean
you gotta have one seed before you have
three you know what i'm saying i'm just
trying to work just like that's why i'm
not hitting on you john grissom a little
weird but whatever the firm and [ __ ] but
uh
i think i'm on the judges list right now
but i'm starting out but that's all
right yeah where did you get older you
want that knowledge especially when you
have kids i'll never forget i went to
dinner with brian when i first moved to
la and brian hangs out with some very
smart people like very well-read people
and we went to this dinner and they're
having this conversation they might as
well have been speaking [ __ ] chinese
dude i was like i have n complex brian
goes you're quiet
i don't have nothing to say it's like me
when you guys talk about gears i was
like i have nothing to offer dude and
then you started watching you got to
read and since that day man [ __ ] do
you are you reading oh dude
i go through a book i mean he reads them
yeah no i i went because i'm on the road
so much i can't read at home because of
the kiddos but i'm the road planes i
finished books
yeah
you know what i enjoy being on a [ __ ]
plane yeah i'm alone i don't know
[ __ ] yeah man pull the book out pull the
book out i've been that's what i read a
lot on airplanes lately like and like
what the kids are going right now really
do a damn thing all day long so like
like i sit there and i read like during
the day instead of watching tv
i will suggest a very heady book but a
good one um
crisis of the west by renegadon written
in like
1929 or
17. yeah what's the uh what's it about
it's about the the declining aspect of
western culture that's cool really in 19
[ __ ] turn of the century right it's
dead this guy's already writing about it
and then then if you get through that
then go to the reign of quantity
that that i i love i love hey world
world war ii stuff i love all world war
ii nazi software you got to start with
you got to start well i mean yeah serial
killer's on board i i had a podcast on
fox for a minute and one of the breaking
points was i said i want to bring
someone on who's about the who can talk
about in-depth detail the nazi occult
[ __ ] like it's bonkers like it's the
formation of like every [ __ ] wild
movie we can think of yeah that'd be
fascinating they said no no they're like
oh we don't have nazis i go no i don't
want to talk to a [ __ ] nazi
i want to [ __ ] talk about this crazy
[ __ ] from history yes i don't no this
isn't pro-nazi morons
that i don't want to deliver a subpar
product and knowing the kind of research
it'll take if you want to talk about
anything current politics or anything
you got to really be thorough because
there's not experts out there that's why
i tell him i'm like dude like you do you
have five podcasts like how do you find
he's like dude he's like i used to be
worried about material and everything
else he's like and now i just it's just
become my life it's just like i just i
have this grasp and it's good when you
have good producers and people around
you they help you out with this i have
some brilliant people around me and then
you know
most of it's company the only podcast
where it's like straight like i got to
do research is the shop show which is
fighting stuff so i'll be researching
guys but outside that like king this
thing it's i've been crazy
to do stuff about fighting and like i
don't want to talk about and they're
just like no there's so much more to you
than fighting now
no i don't want to [ __ ] talk about
fighting at all
as a guy who's
basically has his black belt in podcast
and your idea should not be on fighting
as much as yami could allude to it but
dude
every podcast rogan has nothing to do
with fighting like we might talk about
fighting for 30 minutes and then the
rest of it's like no civilizational
philosophy like all kinds of [ __ ] like
that i called rogan before you coming on
here and uh like because i went back and
listening to episode with rogan before
he came in here
and i was talking rogan yesterday and i
go dude the thing about josh is he's so
[ __ ] smart and rogan goes smart smart
[ __ ] man he's a smart
[ __ ] where there's something
there's not a lot of you know as far as
the fight game goes it's no disrespect
but as far as like your knowledge and
like knowledge on history and sure your
vocabulary like it's rare you know and
then you know what there there's there's
plenty of folks i've come across that
maybe
don't say
vocabulary level aren't on the same
level that's fine but their intelligence
is still there right and so articulating
it in an entertaining way which makes us
successful the fact that i have these
interests that that bring me into these
these four a's is one thing um
you know just like dos angelos here is
getting stupid just he's hanging with
all kinds of dumbass
why is he standing there but i mean it's
13 seconds left in the fight you're
winning every time
has been winning but mcconnell is going
out by the way
is joe fury
oh what'd
he went to a rogan stand-up show which
you know rogan does [ __ ] giant things
sure does
and he had to take a piss so he walked
out when rogan got on stage he's like
dude i know he saw me walk out i'm like
i'm as a comic he's done big venues i
can't see [ __ ] dude the lights are so
bright i can see the first three rows
after that yeah i do it could be sold
out i have no idea what's going on four
or five years i was like
[ __ ] i didn't need to ask him i'm
telling him
he has a dick and a bladder too yeah he
kind of understands that he wouldn't be
mad at you if he if he had a thing he
would be like matt we were like matthew
we're like matthias why did you [ __ ] out
on my [ __ ] set and you're like what
if in the middle whoa whoa matt are you
serious i give you [ __ ] front rows
yeah kayla's gotta poop what are you
doing dude how about last night i put my
mom at the laughing just seen me do
stamp like six years
so i go i was second to last that was
chris delea halfway through chris's act
i'm i'm in the green room i see my mom
passed away i go mama what are you doing
she goes i i swear she goes to take a
[ __ ] i've had
she goes i've had six coffees
she goes you think chris knows i'm gonna
go
no and she goes we're going to get going
i was like what the [ __ ] that's
happening right now yeah like i'm
motoring but yeah i'm motoring i got
stuff happening and i got things in my
mind she goes i have six coffees can
she'll order uber now
i guess mama yeah sounds good [ __ ]
good scrap between these two and from
mcconnell on short notice
tough [ __ ] but uh democracy rda just had
way too much um
uh in terms of
alternative aspects to attach to attack
moykano using the double leg well he's
been in there
he's he's great
you know what
big respect the monster no i agree oh
for sure
damage look at rda man he's been in a
fight it was stupid it was stupid for
for for um dos ano stand there at the at
the last minute i agree with you and i'm
a i'm an expert on stupid
right like i understand like you don't
want to bail out but why would you put
yourself at risk you won everything josh
how long before every champion is from
dagestan or russia oh three years ago
hungary is [ __ ] what are we three
years out yes
and they're all they're all so well
versed in wrestling dude
even though you know he lives in sweden
and trades in sweden but he's dagger
standing no his beard just goes around
for [ __ ] dude
he's a scary mother they just announced
he's on the april 9th card uh against
gilbert burns after he beats gilbert
who's ranked number three it's off to
the [ __ ] races dude that's a scary
dude speaking about bladders i'm gonna
go empty mine real quick go get a bunny
good yeah no i'm glad i've got that
support from you guys yeah we got you
we're not rogan here we're not gonna
shame you yeah not that broken does it
do i thought rogan has the bladder of a
camel haven't you never done rogan show
no never dude it'll be and he's like you
want coffee whiskey i'm
hydrating i'm like i'm going to piss my
pants and he just i've never seen him
take a piece of paper
we'll do companions they're five hours
yeah we talked so long my eyes are like
i can't you know what he talks down so
long your eyes get all [ __ ] up i was
like dude i have to how do you not pee
he's like i don't know he has the
bladder of a [ __ ] camel dude like
forever how old he is that dude is a
[ __ ] killer like you watch his
workouts you see what his bite is how he
eats like that dude is a [ __ ]
physically yeah sure you're monster
savage but as far as you know comedy in
uh his podcast you know he's doing five
shows three hours long a day and you're
talking he's such a worker monday
through yeah you know i i pride myself
on being a workhorse but compared to him
yeah [ __ ] you know
i mean there's no better mentor to have
like in in your game and what you're
doing there's absolutely no better
person to watch his work ethic watch how
he succeeds and he's so hyper successful
and yet at the same time he still works
like he's a peasant correct i mean it's
so dope man and like and like there's
there's so much you see of him that is
so admirable right and the way conducts
himself and the way like he's humble as
[ __ ] and it's like something came up and
he's like hey man like if you guys are
feeling sick that's my perspective on
something like
he's also like the thing i love about it
most is he's so open-minded so if you
came in with one perspective and he had
a hard stance at something and you go
well you never thought about this and
this he's like yeah [ __ ] you're right
yeah like that's the way
intelligent people work you're not gonna
die on a hill when someone's giving you
facts yeah if you do you're stupid
that's it yeah but also the the way the
media has treated him you know i have
this art my my boy r baines mate here
that's dope yeah public enemy number one
have all these guns pointed at rogan
it's [ __ ] that's great that's awesome
by the way dude the guy uh posted it and
someone was like you see this r in rogue
and i hit the artist i'm like dude i
want the original give me the one of one
[ __ ] ship it whatever it cost send it
to me right now let's do it we just got
it in but uh that's great is that pencil
yeah uh i don't know how he did it paint
i don't [ __ ] paint brush
yeah he's a [ __ ] monster but
after seeing the way the media has
portrayed him and treated him
i'm out i mean the way social media and
all that stuff has done him i was
already out and to begin with social
media but as far as the way like the
mainstream has portrayed them
well dude like i i firmly but we i can't
remember if we talked about this before
but like i've i really firmly do believe
that social media was the beginning of
the end of the world it was the
beginning of the of the drastic
polarization of the world and it was the
beginning of of everybody
becoming negative and and critical for
sure like
negativity and credit and and everyone a
voice whether or not they should have
one whether they should be expressing it
at that time and whether or not that
they had the foundational
understanding of any given situation
that they should weigh into it um you
know really it became more about
getting
likes and retweets that's it just like
trying to dunk on things but it's also
what gets likes and retweets is
negativity if you say joe roman's best
community of all time you're not going
to get towards that so our brain
they've done studies on the media rush
and and studies on human beings that
that negativity will get a more positive
neurological response than positivity
yeah that's so so that's where
conditions runs of course because look
at think of it evolutionarily
the things that are dangerous to you are
the things you're going to be more aware
of and more and give more care more
caution
more
uh interest to but
that's what the mainstream media is too
like think about all the the stuff that
they want click on so it's you would
think right now like we're so divisive
and everything's terrible in the cartel
and you know war and all this stuff it's
so divisive when really it's not it's
it's it's not that polaroid well the
world's not it only takes a little bit
of people being in the actual personal
presence of one another i agree for that
to change when you actually have to look
you know it's it's like the uh
the car theory right so you're driving
around a car someone does whatever and
you're cursing and swearing you're
saying everything about them and
everything about their ancestors that
you could ever think of
and then all of a sudden you actually
have to see that person if someone does
something in your person
a totally different animal no yeah
you probably won't even say anything
nope yeah although for sure
there's times where i've been like [ __ ]
i don't wanna i don't wanna i don't
wanna i don't wanna it's like
yep
okay
are we gonna have a problem right now
right
does it does anybody [ __ ] with you josh
no never no all right and people are
like oh i know who you are i go no
so nobody knows who the [ __ ] i am uh
but
i think the difference is is that if i
speak to someone
in that tone if i approach them about
something that could be
to violence because all conversations
have violence at their at their base
violence is the golden rule violence is
the thing in which all human interaction
is stems from that's at the base of it
because you can have you can well that's
a that's a really loaded take well you
can communicate to all levels right
you're going to understand everybody in
terms of as soon as i say a you say b
we can find no common ground
at some point there is an understanding
that violence could be the only
solutions
the issue is that all courtesies all
considerations all like historical
societal courtesies built from whatever
society you want to come from across all
historical time
even built built into religious tomes
all right it's an understanding that
violence is at its right is an option
yeah i don't i don't hate what you're
saying i just never thought of it before
so in any case
when i speak to someone and and that's
potentially where we're headed with this
i do it in such a way that i say well
you know
i'm fully engaged
and that's fine and i don't mind and
that's that's the thing where they're
like no because most people
they don't want to actually engage in
violence what they want is to save face
in such a way so that whatever that
confrontation is being in a bar whatever
it's like well you see i told him i
could [ __ ] him up and blah blah blah
blah and then we get separated and you
know if we'd really fought it's it's
because at
at the end of the day
even an animal knows that so when people
like to go on about like alpha wolves
and all this kind of stuff well you know
alphas don't fight right unless they
absolutely have to yeah because
if you get you know a fight as an animal
you get maimed hurt injured whatever
that could take you not only out of the
gene pool entirely because
you could die from infection or all
these other things or you could be so
lamed that you're no longer alpha and
now some other beta is going to come up
and take your spot and so even we're not
any different from any animal all that
much besides you know will and
consciousness but we still have some of
these internal instincts ourselves and
that is
look if we go out and we get into a
fight
and we get injured and even you can even
think of societal pressures like well if
i get into a fight maybe i can get
arrested maybe there's all these other
things
suing is fun when people get really
mouthy about well i'll just sue you i go
well you'll be sue me from a [ __ ]
you're gonna sue me over this then
you'll sue me from a wheelchair i'll
break your spine i'll make sure your
dick never works
i'm gonna take your eye out i'll leave
you one so you can see the wreckage that
you've become yeah enjoy your lawsuit
one eye yeah exactly so you can see
yourself in a mirror every day to see
what a pathetic little sack of [ __ ] i've
turned you into could you imagine if you
heard somebody say that to you i'd be
like holy [ __ ] i told a guy i thought it
would be cool
i told the group of people once i said
you don't have you better call some
friends because you don't have enough
people here right now to save your ass
or i've told people like well i can call
a cop like go ahead they'll never get
here in time they couldn't stop me
anyways they're not going to make time
man yeah by the time i'm done with you
there's not going to be anything left
dissolve if i still want to keep going
they're not stopping me yeah if i'm
going to jail i'm going to earn i got i
got [ __ ] booked on some dumbass [ __ ]
once way back in the day like totally
stupid nonsense thing i didn't even know
you could go to jail for this and i
remember i'm i get up out of the car i'm
taking my jack cops got his taser ready
and all this he's like sir sir sir like
i just turned over my show i look at him
i go that's not a good idea
and i just took my jacket off put it in
the car
jesus christ i'll tell you what is a
good idea use in manscape
you need our friends at manscape they
have the routine for you the all-new
ultra premium collection
skin in here non-natural cork yeah man
yeah there you go is designed to upgrade
the everyday man's shower routine from
head to toe your skin here and balls
deserve this save big by going to
manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping with the code cfc we got it all
the lather on cologne infused ultra
premium body wash ultra premium yes aloe
vera
that sea salt is exfoliating dude two
and one sharon who rubs you up dude we
got uh body order stuff to protect you
from we got uh freaking hydrating body
moisturizer spray uh apply the manscape
lip balm blood you got ashy lips
aluminum free deodorant because aluminum
reduces your testosterone true fact
facts that's in most of those things i
don't wear it oh you don't wear
deodorant i don't wear deodorant oh
you're you're the uh uh uh henry rollins
type oh he's like he wants his natural
pheromones out there
hey
yeah what's up man uh get 20 from free
shipping with the code cfc manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with a
code cfc at manscape.com it's time to
get wet and clean with your new manscape
shower routine all right main event boys
how's it all kobe covington i'm going to
love both of these guys more yeah
i mean i know that people have their
opinions on both these guys for things
that they say outside of the ring but
honestly never care about that me
neither because i've never met covington
but i must a great guy you would love
him
george is my boy yeah yeah and i think i
think it's called maz vidal been solid
from day one and when he was in
strikeforce i would say this
[ __ ] is no one to be [ __ ] with
no one to treat lightly no one do uh
him you know he's the third highest paid
fighter you've seen good yeah
good you know you know anytime you can
make 50 bucks and 100 you know it's good
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry i'm just
[ __ ] with ufc no but yeah
this fight you know people always ask me
what a bet on this one's tough because
they know each other so well you know it
is when you fight friends it's just i'm
like
and he's got to stay on his bike
until
because kobe is uh
i'm sorry colby is
volume pressure intensity and gas tank
yes guessed for gates so it's it's not a
matter of whether or not george is in
shape or not but if i'm a betting man
i'm going to say
it's not worth putting that to task
against covington no it just isn't
because that's that's where covington
excels i agree the bet i liked was i
think mazda plus 350 to win by ko
because if he's going to win it's he's
not winning by decision no he's not he
has to finish it and he's a one-hitter
quitter but not
so much and and and covington's hard to
take out one he's never happened as far
as i know remember like and
he has a great wrestling pedigree uh
marty absolutely got out on um on both
of them right marty got out on both of
them but that's what's weird to me is
big and marty has such a good um
he's hard to take so colby wants to take
him down right yeah covington's trying
to get that take down marty is such a
stud on the wall yeah dude that he's
hard to deal with and he and he's a
solid defensive wrestler and he started
working trevor whitman for those boxing
yeah
trevor is killing it dude with moz vidal
now it's the opposite
now you've got now you've got usman you
know uh using his wrestling skills to
stifle mos vidal and keep that out of
the the realm of just a pure striking
matter there you go jorge maslow
ko tko uh plus 400. nice well that's
that's the bet to make for sure yeah i
mean 400 trying to make money yeah plus
400 but 100 1 400. dude i'm i don't bet
on sports because i would mean
everything dude yeah everything i'm not
doing i do the only thing i bet on is
i'll go if i'm in vegas i'll go to the
biggest
um progressive
no that loses
slot machine yeah i put 100 bucks in it
i run it i go if i'm lucky i don't i
don't want to be lucky for five 10 grand
like what's the point of that i want to
be lucky i'll be like three million yeah
yeah otherwise
yeah i can't i can't can't fault that
but i'll tell you what you should be the
logic master yeah the logic master
that's your new name as you're getting
older
that's why we're gonna slide down to
variance mastery
um i mean you're [ __ ] us out with
some truth today josh that's what i'm
saying
yeah i mean this is what uh what people
on on uh
[ __ ] fight companion are interested
they're like oh yeah i can't wait to get
moldova in romanian history when he came
out and broke up geography i was like ah
[ __ ] this
i was watching tv for a while ago
you're talking about gears and
carbon dioxide things i was like sweetie
and chris is bullshitting about octopus
um all right so listen who takes it
uh uh
the gun to the head i know
boy i'm going colby i'm going george
here's i love both of them but i i'm i'm
closer with colby i think uh
i think he's the best
in the world minus the ice really then
add the ice okay all right only only
saying
it's going to get smokier from the water
from the ice
so i just want you to try it without the
ice just give it a
give it a taste listen i'm going to be
totally honest with you josh um i got
drunk as [ __ ] at breakfast today
oh surprise what a surprise it was
probably all on the white claws yeah so
no
and it was being inspired
and i didn't realize hitler's fork right
that's my spot yeah i get my bikes fixed
there well it's a great place and i got
hammer i mean i'm [ __ ] blasted at
breakfast and i was like i think do i
gotta do a podcast i have to go home and
pass out picked up some chick like some
chicken named tessa like where at pelosi
yeah like at eight o'clock
it was it was two children's fork is in
calabasas oh yeah they have 10 speed
coffee there but uh i i road bike all
the time but i fix my bikes there are
you just trying to get giant legs
uh you know i gotta do some so i don't
[ __ ] know you're you're right you're
right all right yeah you
here's a here's something that people
don't understand by the way
i'm just going to speak specifically for
these two
they can tell me if i'm if i'm wrong or
not
they live their life and you and you you
need to understand this they lived a
life of being a [ __ ] high level
athlete
[ __ ] you and about talking about their
records and who they want or lost to get
sure no
they went through football at a serious
level yeah they went and took it all the
way to as far as it can go
that's a commitment yes that is that is
literally a lifestyle choice it really
is yeah
do you get on the other end of this well
then they go ufc right they go to become
professional mma fighters again you get
on the end of this and there's a party
that wants to go like
so we're done with that right i know
like we could just kind of sloth around
a bit you're like a greyhound but you
really need to keep it going you have to
you really do yeah because it's
something
exactly you have to find something there
that's where i'm going to channel that
energy into something
yeah yeah well to have kids it's very
pointed very pointed energy you kayla
for a test and see if that's acceptable
um but you did say you picked up a girl
i picked her up so i don't it's a live
show too
you can't edit that out no no no i'm not
you want to tell you you should check
your phone right now absolutely
that's a smart enough guy where i
literally literally i just got a text
from kayla boy
are you just like well you know yeah
i'm just
i was trying to make josh laugh you know
he's [ __ ] around it's just a joke
don't check text record today josh
intimidated me with his big words
his geography knowledge it overwhelmed
yeah i couldn't help it his romanian
geography [ __ ] me up yeah
um i think i think kobe wins i think
that kobe is just gonna have so much
pressure um that it's gonna it's gonna
be frustrating i mean unless jorge gets
off on him with a knee or something like
that and
george is so
calm yeah i mean he fights
i talked to him and gill melendez after
they fought
separately
and i told gil i go man if he just
stayed on the low kicks you were in a
you were in a world of hurt and he goes
i know that and i luckily he didn't he
got away from it and and gail was able
to get his hands going and get his
penetration steps into his and the
takedowns and everything i told george i
go why'd you stop low kicking him he
goes i go you [ __ ] up you had him
you had him
what's interesting about jorge too is
remember if you watch remember how big
kimbo slice was with those backyard
fights jorge's in most of those that's
right he started he started off fighting
he was like seven fights
yeah
he is he i love jorge game bread is a
perfect nickname for him and i love dan
lambert and all of
those att cats so yeah i just thought it
was great man
it's fascinating with kobe obviously
took this hard trump stance and all that
stuff it's also brilliant man i mean
yeah i mean being polarizing is going to
get you interest no matter what
difference right but he's the best
walked away on the planet not named
kumar usman like if kamara was born 10
years later last fight was a [ __ ]
knockdown dog fight like oh knock knock
dog i would watch a fight every weekend
man yeah take my [ __ ] money and use
man never met the guy but he seems like
a solid he's a really good guy he's a
really good dude i think that um
i think that he
got he got a taste of the machine
and then once he got a taste of the
machine was like
this okay that's a good point yeah
that's good
you know when rhonda finally blew up
her fighting was enough right but that
wasn't doing it it was getting in what i
also i also call it the machine once you
get the pr stuff you go on ellen they
just softball you all this stuff
whatever it's like that was the thing
that made her a household name and put
those pay-per-views out because her
fighting capability yeah was
absolutely phenomenal yeah but for
whatever reason that wasn't doing you
had to do the personal pr you had to be
in the pr machine right you had to have
these [ __ ] pr girls
guys like you and the whole yeah heavy
lies the crown man a lot of champions
love all that pr stuff and a lot of them
hate well a lot of people love it until
they have it right until they have to do
it and then once you have to do it and
you get flown around the world you don't
have time to rest you hear what khabib
said because
uh he was getting ready for his main
event and they're like they have a the
camera on him and he they asked him to
do another interview he's like another
one and khabib goes hey this can't all
stop just lose just lose and you don't
have to do this anymore just lose uh
yeah it's it's so true he's like just
lose you won't have to worry about this
what you can allow yourself to give away
and what you can't
and you need someone by your side and
that for a fighter and i would say like
ron is a good example of this and i've
talked to travis about this i go she
just she needed somebody by her side to
guide her through this because she could
get the most out of it
um without having to be
succumbed to this [ __ ] and the machine
by the way doesn't care if when you fall
out of it no not at all because there
will be another person correct and so
the machine machine's waiting well use
up rhonda yes until she's got nothing
left and then be like we don't give a
[ __ ] anymore
like there's zero love and all those
people that she met before them in nunes
she was like i'm not doing press man no
no she's power yeah she's smart with
that rondo's again you know there's
the terminator
and and by by putting her into positions
without the right people to back her up
is almost kind of criminal like she's
the terminator
and she's great at it and she is she's
just a smart person very smart but but
this kind of [ __ ] world [ __ ] with a
person like that no matter who you are
exactly like
whether it's hollywood or exactly or
fighting or sports it's going to she got
she got served up some [ __ ] that
nobody prepped her for
and she
well she was the first one she was the
first one nobody saw the machine like
rhonda did right yes because she didn't
know nobody had any idea who what was
behind the curtain until rhonda was like
okay i get it now and rhonda figured out
after a while how to play the game and
she played it perfectly for her but she
went a little bit into the and again the
main weather territory the mayweather
territory where it's like whoa over here
you know yeah and it's like
she's got so much more than that like
she's
she's so much more of a a a person than
than is just a sound bite yeah she's a
sweetheart man she's a great person yes
yeah and uh yeah grace to ever do it
fantastic yeah incredible uh this is
incredible that
colby has gotten this takedown and it's
stuck to him now i thought i was such a
vet that i'm sure he's calm as [ __ ]
right now and a-okay but even still the
problem with this is there's only five
five-minute rounds correct when i was at
the end of the deal with cormier
i'm thinking if we keep going yo i can't
wait for the next round this
[ __ ] doesn't even want to be
here anymore yeah
whoops that's five
uh he's won enough rounds yeah i've lost
yeah god damn it dan and that's the
sport god damn it danny yeah danny
cormier big old danny c you god
[ __ ] second son of a [ __ ] and that's
[ __ ] winning
yeah no i mean
when i look back when i was thinking of
when i think back on i'm like yes
[ __ ] and all his olympic
wrestling [ __ ] knowing
when he scored how we scored what the
time is
god
and that now experience he and he's
tough as [ __ ] you know what else let's
talk about this if we're gonna talk
about daniel cormier i feel like every
time i talk about him i want to talk
about [ __ ] anthony johnson and how
anthony hit him with that straight right
and literally launched him across the
damn cage and he he kept his composure
he didn't trip and then and just stayed
on he cormier is the consummate
professional all the time he's in the
game he's a gamesman now he's not
an annihilator yep but
he is a games a gamesmanship dude he
knows strategy he knows how to hang in
there he is a guy that will compete with
you at every level that [ __ ]
will compete with you about anything
anything oh you know how to do a podcast
well i'll you do three cameras i'll do
four i'll do this he will compete about
everything and uh you know why he's not
on the broadcast tonight because his uh
mom passed away oh
funerals today that's like in there yeah
i didn't know that that's tough
elbows daniel um
rest in peace to your mom she obviously
um put a lot of effort into helping you
and raise you
and you got to be hurting right now but
uh
i'm just saying nothing but love i'm
going to send you a text when we leave
now think think about his mom password
and then also he's really close with
kane yeah and then oh the whole game
yeah that's tough okay for dc right now
man yeah that's a tough go man i i
called luke if guys are out there on
twitter guys and gals
send them some love yeah simply
for nothing that you that you need to
get out of anything simply do this
simply for the selfless act of helping
somebody when they're going through a
tough time and it's not about
reciprocation either
he will be appreciated
um
and and you know what i'll i'll
uh uh for my own sake say like for all
of you out there when you're going
through these kind of tough things
i don't need to say it
but i understand
and i'm with you too we're all in this
together we're all trying to make it to
this world one way or the other we all
have the same struggles
all three of us we know what depression
is we know what anxiety is we know what
all these things are and we know what
what it means to suffer through things
but the ultimate thing at the end of the
day is you have to overcome that
suffering and it's kind of sometimes it
has to come from the the help of someone
else from outside yeah but at the end of
the day but but you can do it we can all
do it we've all been there
trusting dc too you know he's gone
through some tough times because i think
he had a daughter passed away as well
yeah
dude talking about that just it reminded
me
a good buddy of mine uh when i told him
about what really happened with kane and
the situation behind it
um the first thing he said was okay we
need to find out where he's at so we can
put money on his books we need to make
his life as comfortable as possible i
think eric ransom did a gofundme did he
yeah okay and all that that money goes
to go in the books yeah i think i think
he's raised a hundred thousand dollars i
i talked about yeah i talked to a lawyer
and that he was like the the paying the
the
attorney fees is going to help yeah yeah
he's like you got to hope this thing
goes to trial man so he's going to be
expensive
yeah
i think anybody that's a parent or just
has a conscience knows hey man this
shit's got to you're like vigilante
justice isn't the answer but you can't
send somebody to prison for for
protecting his family like that someone
wrote a good article and i i don't i
can't imagine what kane felt the rage
that he felt but someone wrote a good
article just saying like
free kane but also by his actions you
know no matter what happens he's going
away no matter what yeah he's going to
do his time
so this article was saying i forget who
wrote it i think it was mma mania or mma
junkie but he's saying that the shame is
is because of these actions now that
four-year-old who obviously was molested
whatever is going to grow up without a
father now so it's like that molester
and a thirteen-year-old when she
needs her pedophile is gonna miss out on
a dad and also have this you know
baggage of being molested so it's like
again it goes back to what i said like
this is
civilizational
incompatible
the you you can't [ __ ] with kids the
domino effect
is is too much you [ __ ] their life up
forever well you [ __ ] the family up
forever like you don't get everything
you do
like you the whole fam the whole this
sounds terrible it's like god i hate
saying this but like the whole family
dies at that moment like the kid has
issues and will have issues but the
whole family is gonna have like [ __ ]
forever and that's like i said like i
would have yeah i would have i would i
would have tried it around the pedophile
i'm trying to be cool that person would
have stuck in and killed that until his
dad got shot
that's what i'm talking about like even
and i'm not saying i'm assuming that
dad's a scumbag too though
to let him be around yeah but think
about being having her son being a
pedophile and it's your son
what do you do
i don't think multiple times thought
about too like not just like hey bobby
just there's there's no aspect to this
it's already been bad yeah it just goes
bad on so many levels i i don't know how
you do it but i only let three people
watch my kids
nobody watching nobody else can yeah
grandma grandpa yeah that's it yeah
grandma grandpa and then we have a
caretaker no that's the reason why
that's one of the reasons why i see you
shut off fellas i stayed in with my job
as long as i did uh with with fighting
like because i he knows i've i never
liked fighting like i love that i love
competition yeah you didn't really seem
like someone was like oh i love getting
socked in the face yeah yeah you're
you're not gonna tell a stitch let me
die in there yeah like it's it's not my
go right i love competing but yeah
fighting's not my thing um but like um
there were so much time and did the
whole no look it's an espn
issue wow they crashed they'll get a
fixed asap they got the mouse on it
right now
donald duck kicked out the [ __ ] bnc
connector thank you thank you
also thanks for 80
yeah all right um but like uh um i can't
remember what we're just talking about
i wouldn't let anybody watch my kids but
the reason i like my job so much i
stayed in the ufc was because i was a
stay-at-home dad so when they go to
school or whenever when they were young
i was home right it wasn't a situation
or i i i was like like tina at the time
yeah tina would be able to be home with
the kids i love this
i had to think about latino time frame
yeah it's tina yeah yeah you're gonna
get another text mat wow
really boy
[Laughter]
sometimes i'll screw up man and like
like
i'll be i'll be saying something like
i'll be talking to kayla like hey and
she's like i [ __ ] heard that
do you blame it on ct
my ct is flaring up baby
olivia
the ct is flaring up baby oh god it was
bad man oh
sure you know covington's been landing a
decent amount on the feet the volume
it's the volume of cover it has not
really been no he's not being able to
get off and then also covington's not
shooting from far out where those knees
are you know he's
yeah i mean front quarter that's great
but what do you do with it again you can
walk away from the fence uh-huh now your
feet are starting to take now you're
getting taken down dude god damn it
that's what i yeah [ __ ] george that's
what i felt i sprawled against bader and
then like i felt him just kept he
i never felt the urgency of a shot like
that before either of you ever trained
with bobby lashley yes
did he shoot from like 8 000 feet away
dude and you went like ha ha no you're
down
he was a denver guy he was yeah
he trained with me my boy i used to
train him for his fights that's my god
everything yeah that's my guys small 10
thousand my guy that's my guy
smallest head smallest in the world yeah
jack dude
we had nate markhart shane carwin gsb
you name it i've never seen him get
taken down todd duffy everybody i've
never seen bobby lashley on his back
ever i've i've taken to i've taken bobby
down i was gonna say i bet you got him
by half an hour and
you have to do something never
let it go i [ __ ] i mean he took me
down he's got more takedowns against me
than i've run against him but i [ __ ]
rub it in have you trained so hard
i have a scar on my back to this day
it's a long because he had long
fingernails and we were wrestling he's
trying to get me down i was defended and
just scratched my back and i was all
sweaty like in the my coach goes dude it
looks like wolverine oh my god i'm back
my entire trunks [ __ ] bobby
this is such a guy who was training at
this training at the gym he goes i
watched him change levels from like two
feet away and i thought
yeah good luck oh god no he's right
there
i [ __ ] stupid i knocked his tooth out
no with a knee no he ducked he i was
[ __ ] tagging him he ducked into a uh
he ducked in with his head down and i
changed levels and he [ __ ] caught it
on the top of my head and popped his
tooth out of course he guilted the [ __ ]
out of me and i'm like [ __ ] bob come
on man i'm just trying to help you out
he's like yeah he helped me into a
[ __ ] dental build yeah like
dude if if he started mma younger and
focused on mma world championship i love
bobby bobby is and he's i've gotten to
wrestle him a couple times amazing pro
wrestling he's in the wwe yes amazing
champion i don't know he's a champion
yeah no he's great josh explain this to
me i don't understand how you're the
perfect guy for this job i don't
understand the infatuation i don't
understand why people like grown men are
showing to wwe have you ever watched a
marvel movie
no that's not my thing i've been
watching any okay name name a movie
you're gonna watch uh schwarzenegger
films when i was kid yes yeah yeah
you're not hard he's a grown man
i'm just saying
do you watch this
heroic journey sure that's all it is it
is the culmination the male soap opera
sort of it's not
it's just that pro wrestling is a
is a microcosm of society
contained
in a ring
it is it is overcoming struggling
all these things there's a heel there's
a hero a face yeah it is basically and
often a lot of external elements from
politics and society at large and global
elements will all blend themselves into
that wow dude kobe is really you know
that's his game buddy
he's putting so much pressure you've
always loved it josh like always always
oh i watched
the wwf awa and then started seeing you
the uwf shoot style stuff
uh from japan new japan pro wrestling
and just got really into it and you love
it well and all the catch guys
all have a lineage back to professional
wrestling that i trained on there matt
hughes that's right
gotch or robinson billy robinson so
billy robinson i got to train with
directly
in japan
and then with carl gotch i got to train
a little bit with him in florida and but
also matt hume trained under massa
fanaki and mino suzuki who trained under
gotcha but isn't it weird for you josh
to go from this bare knuckle fight with
this mongolian savage with tattoos all
his face to faking it and no because
it's two sides of the same coin
so we're flipping the same point i'm
either doing a work match or i'm doing a
shoot both physical both physical
hitting but one is pre-meditated
determined
the other one's not that's it
um and when i do bloods when we do blood
sport i'm just like what's blood sport
that's my professional wrestling mm-hmm
josh barnett's bloodsport eight is gonna
happen in uh dallas texas as a part of
the collective hell yeah you get your
tickets now when is it uh march 31st
hell yeah during wrestlemania weekend
the wrestlemania week and uh
we've got john moxey versus biff busick
we've got uh john john morrison now
going to john hennigan his actual name
is going to be there
uh
we have uh alex coughlin versus slade we
have a whole lineup of of killer
athletes marina shafir is in it who's a
student of mine oh and she was a ronda's
training partner she was fighting the
ufc she was not the ultimate fighter
she was on the uf she was on the
ultimate fighter with ron but she never
fought in the ufc she fought invicta
you still mess with
harry oh all the time
harry harry is one of my i i've been
training harry smith the son of the
british bulldog yeah baby boy
he was great dude 19 20 years old yeah i
took him into his first strip club
yes
so you're a corrupter that's what you're
saying basically so his dad's the
british bulldog was one of us his dad's
a british bulldog yeah there were two
there were brothers wrong as sure well
no no not no but uh there was uh tom
billington who was the british who was
um
uh
jesus christ uh uh dynamite kid and then
you had the british bulldog who's dave
boy smith did you ever did you ever uh
flirt with actually wwe or you're you no
i've never
going over there and working but i know
triple h i know
all the main people and i i i'm the
manager for shayna paisler who's in the
wwe are you really yeah i do she's done
a really great job and i've said she was
also is she in the wwe now where she's
on she's next or something right she was
on nxt she's one of the longest reigning
women's champions in nxt that's history
she moved over to wwe so i'm her manager
and still her coach that's dope and uh
and that was a conversation where
all right
you seem like you're kind of losing the
love for fighting but you're really
into pro wrestling and you've got to
help yourself go into
you want us you want to go into pro
she's crushing it and she just goes
yeah i want to make that transition okay
okay done so i just started training her
guy for the job i brought in chavo
guerrero jr i brought in bobby i bring
i'd make her train with everyone i could
and i trained her up from from start to
finish and manager and now we got her to
the wwe in like two years i saw that she
was at a show in indianapolis and we
actually went to the show to go just
because she was on the show just to
watch and that was the only wrestling
show i've ever been to that's cool
it was a it was a hell of a uh spectacle
wasn't it yeah it was great dude i've
heard wrestlemania is like oh
i want to go to one i want it so insane
so the place where my so my buddy hey
good job george kobe's beating his ass
well george hit a double there but got
elevated kobe is all now he's just
hanging on the legs way too he's not
going to be good
george needs to not be wrestling this
[ __ ]
for sure a good buddy of mine uh lives
down in boca and and the building that
he lives in is mcmahon's
family property that he sold to this
place if he could get like a a floor out
of this building or whatever and so
triple h and mcmahon live in this
building um i've never come across
somebody here they're there and i hear
they're great people like everybody's
like dude they're so polite they're so
cool
personally for me i've never had nothing
but but good exchanges with triple h
yeah with with trips like he's always
been super [ __ ] good to me that's our
nickname for him we call him trips
i don't know about that you laymen don't
really know him like that
[Laughter]
was he the vice president of wwe or is
he the i don't know what his actual
position is at this point but he's
because he's married
married to stephanie stephanie that's
right
um
they're always like like they're they're
they're around from my understand but
i've never come across them did you you
know the ufc based their business model
off wwe of course i 100 percent ufc
fight pass all that everything yeah well
like they were they were trying to get
in bed and then dana wanted to make sure
that he kept a separation because he
didn't want people thinking it was fake
right right and that's why danny came
out with israel as it gets right
um although originally
like the uh
the promotional material around the
early ufc's
worked against them and then a lot of
like
[ __ ] healed politicians that weren't
actually you know weren't doing anything
for any of their constituents then used
the ufc as a bargaining chip to say oh
look i'm protecting you from all this
evil stuff yeah they call it like old
mccain oh yeah by the way john mccain's
the giant piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] my
brother actually not sorry he's a good
piece of [ __ ] the day passed away
the day before we reported for the
ultimate fighter i told i reached out to
my family i was like hey man let you
know this i'm going on this show called
ozma fighter i'll be gone for you know
two months or whatever what six weeks
whatever and he goes
he goes
i'm so [ __ ] disappointed in you
my brother he goes i'm so [ __ ]
he has nothing to do with the ufc and
he's like i can promise you that he's
like that's human [ __ ] fighting he's
like what the [ __ ] are you doing blah
blah and i was like
sweet man so i'll see it a little bit
well
you know where he's leaning with my
strong suit
so i creased my zipper i've wd forwarded
it it's all good no this i'm gonna
succeed at this [ __ ] fighting thing oh
yeah but dude he was not happy about
that at all i got a big head but a small
shaft i'm great i'm good man i got a lot
of rotational force on the end of this
for my hips how about that they call it
human [ __ ] fighting oh they did yeah
yeah of course but you know what john
mccain also was
getting two
budweiser who is one of the biggest
sponsors of all of boxing boxing yeah no
he was
mccain all the money huh that's trash
that's politics ah mccain's trash dude
monster dog is getting his ass beat no
he is getting handled because he's not
working behind his offense he's not
using his strikes to put together his
footwork
anytime i fight a wrestler i i shell up
i cannot
like if i fight a wrestler like when i
fought tyrell i was like i was in such
good shape i had done everything and my
body was great and i was like
i don't want to [ __ ] open up because
i do i'm sure in camp though but you
have to work behind your lead you have
to work behind your lead i know that's
the thing because your lead that was my
thing that keeps him keeps him at bay
keeps him occupied anybody knows me
knows like if i get on the ground i'm
going to lose like that's the best the
best way to even
no matter how much i strain with you it
was just time i just didn't i've never
got it man like i don't know why did you
fight away from your strengths yeah all
right covington's all over him front
headlock socks and he switches from
mutasa
is going to the double yeah he's
lighting them up and because even
staying here now obviously covington
wants his takedown but just by being in
this position creating pressure keeping
him on the fence that clock is winding
down he's already been winning rounds oh
yeah right the more he's about to leave
three to one well so i saw somebody i
saw a couple people on the screen say
that they gave the second random mosfet
all i don't understand how that happened
at all i don't see that either but but
but at the at the very end
we've got still that's three to one
right correct all this time is chewing
down yep right and then you ain't
getting it back they're not going to
stop the clock and give you kobe's just
not giving any chance
you know who the best guy ever saw was
[ __ ] thick boy over here the best guy
ever saw at controlling the clock and
knowing when and uh when to turn along
and when to take a rest randy guitar was
well first of all yes
robbie lawler ah robbie larla would come
out in the first smoke somebody to know
he got out on him and then knew that if
he just coasted just enough he might
lose a second but he knew he would have
enough energy for the third and come get
out gotcha damn kobe oh wow wow he's
lighting up mosbid all right jeez dude
he's he needs to stick with it you
better start punching
he's gonna shoot here wow and here's the
thing
george is not firing he's not one she
needs to be throwing uppercuts
tight space uppercuts elbows head
movement and then walking a little bit
along the cage and letting his offense
go behind him so he can get out of there
rotate without getting tagged with
something dumb because because the the
entrance in the exit is always a big
deal especially when you're dealing with
a grappler how many facial stitches did
you get
enough that i i i couldn't even like
lots lots yeah a few years what was the
worst fight you had where you were oh
[ __ ] he got dropped he got dropped i
didn't see him he's playing that guy in
the fight and and uh dropped him yeah
right hook he's still tucking him he's
still touching him miles had all dropped
him all right he's covered he's well
that's good
he doesn't have a hard one to go knock
him out that's smartest the smartest
thing he's done all day well covington
needs to take that shot at some point
you need to set up and he's giving away
he stay on his bike keep active
yeah he's wobbled he's hurt what um oh
and he's still touching him though oh
[ __ ] george he must be exhausted man
um josh what was the worst what was the
worst injuries
like or the most beat up you were uh
mirko crow cop the finals of the pride
grant open weight grand prix
i got uh
i managed to i landed some decent [ __ ]
on him but not nearly enough he came in
way fresher than me
and uh at some point i'm just like what
did you fight the day before or like was
it day before the night night before the
night before i thought no guerra jesus
christ to a time limit decision when
when i i had him knee-barred he's
screaming and i thought when they
stopped the fight i'm like oh well
that's a verbal tap yeah yeah
no technically it is
nope
oh wow and it was a split win i'm like
split
i [ __ ] dropped him and [ __ ] had
him in a sub like you got to be kidding
me so the guy i forget the guy whose
name uh voted for nogueira but uh you're
a jackass
so to this day yeah to this day
split decision you're right i go and i i
fight crow crop after he murked jesus
christ
and things were not going well but i was
still in it
and uh
i went to scooch under and go after a
leg lock i scooped his leg started going
for it and he he he reacted to try and
escape and he went like this and he
[ __ ] like two knuckles deep in my eye
oh no dude it was an accident it's not
mirko's fault at all but i remember
dudes getting eye gouge and them not
stopping the fight as a hell of a [ __ ]
oh no
they're gonna let mirko just like soccer
kick me into oblivion and i tap that
and then when i see the replay miracle
goes oh [ __ ] i think oh yeah he's got
[ __ ] eye gouge yeah oh yeah like
dumb dude
no but i love i love
mirko me too because that [ __ ]
i've never met him oh he's the best he
is as intense as you can get but also a
solid if you're his friend you're his
[ __ ] friend if i flew to croatia
right now if i jumped on a plane right
now and i hit a miracle and i said hey
i'm in town
he would meet me yeah he would be let's
go
he's just like his dad jack
and krokop had a heart issue we can't
get sanctioned to fight anymore oh damn
it to stop i didn't know that yeah no
anyways uh
solid dude great guy
took incredible care of me in croatia we
went out on the town
beautiful man love him that's awesome
that's the sun there at 18.
wow good god
they're but definitely his kid
oh oh [ __ ] definitely
oh weird backwards florida what are you
doing jesus george i don't know right
tenacity of colby man
is that american wrestler aesthetic
right like that iowa you know he's not
an iowa wrestler but just like constant
pressure
yeah oregon state oregon state he's a
guy okay yeah yeah oh he has a chill guy
in me yeah jail son and oh i got
memories i [ __ ] love
me too
so many people i know solid human being
yeah like from from the day one to today
he's never been anything but the coolest
straightest followed through on anything
he's ever said
[ __ ] full-on chill son and [ __ ]
he's on the show
is he really not the best all right you
know what tell chill like
in his corner all the way like that guy
love him love chase one of my favorites
i get text from taylor and random like
brandon things and he'll be like fired
at something i'm like hey man how's your
life he's like dude i couldn't be
happier he's like but bob blind he talks
about whatever like he texts me he's
like hey what stocks are you in right
now and what's going on here how this
he's like it's stuff that's about
anything other than fighting chair will
chime in at random times great guy yes
yeah
uh oregon state yeah oregon state yeah
dude you know what he did chill was
chad was so great at being chill well
actually chad took his oregon guy
he's in oregon uh oregon state's a
beaver he's a duck yeah yeah technically
yeah yeah yeah merrick channel ran for
what some uh uh office in in port in
oregon yeah didn't win
when they they brought up his dirt of
course
people have asked me like oh you have an
interest you know you have all these
different ideas about politics and this
is like no i am no way
you know what's tougher for george
george is training with oh [ __ ] he's
bleeding uh bo nickel too i bet uh
yeah my sweater was training with bone
nickels because bone nickel was um they
gave him an att for uh for happiness
oh wow so by the way beau nichols
amateur debut like wreck just crushed
did
i'm out sh and i don't get paid yeah i'm
sorry so it's gonna be free buddy there
was in oregon this dude enoch something
i i can't i can't black dude haitian
white okay wild okay close though great
guys so close uh wild man from morgan he
fights um
this dude was like a legit
wrestler he's got this great youtube and
channel all this kind of [ __ ] stuff
god why am i i'm forgetting his name
this dude was like a super stud in
college and high school and everything
yeah
this guy's first mma fight is against
his enoch dude enoch wilson enoch
something and enoch rides him out the
dude gasses and [ __ ] like dismantles
him really yeah but it's that kind of
thing like oh your first fight spilled
nickel your first fight is nightmare
this [ __ ] kid that i cannot remember
his name for some reason josh have you
have you had guys in your camp where in
training you're like oh this guy's gonna
be world champion oh yeah and then the
lights turn on what the
i mean there's gym champs everywhere we
go so crazy weird like the pressure like
that some people flourish and some
people just can't handle that man that's
so odd
uh we have a we have a guy in
indianapolis that's that's like that
that was so good he would smoke lytle
that was great yeah it's like oh this
guy's never gonna lose he couldn't show
up to a 200-person fight yeah like could
just couldn't do it he would find
reasons but like i i can't my i gotta
watch my kids today i can't come is that
crazy
there's guys like that in football too
oh for sure for sure
um by the way uh marcus jones name came
up in my life the other day how big baby
big baby uh the darkness
remember nobody gives himself a nickname
yeah yeah
a friend of mine uh
yeah aaron johnson
down in florida just took a job with
stryker gary colett by the way is what i
was trying to remember
carrie colott from first
first no i don't remember where he's
from i couldn't know uh first and only
mma fight enoch whatever oh cause that
[ __ ] gasses out gets taken out yes
um so uh he's like he's like hey man
like wow you're a big dude because i
played in the nfl with aaron like god
you're a big dude last big dude we had
was a guy named marcus johnson he's like
michael jones he's like marcus jones
he's like yeah i know that name
yeah i know that guy i know that yeah
did he really take everybody in training
margaret jones yes i don't know he was
on their team i don't know i don't know
[Music]
yeah he was tough
oh that sucks yeah that's some hostility
george lost i was hoping they'd be
friends after this yeah man who knows
but hard to say oh man look at him there
[ __ ]
colby
look at that
yeah you had to fight that yeah that's
but he was
a great a specimen we knew we had no
chin we knew we both fought him to get
our ticket to the ufc because i found on
the
finals the semifinals to fight roy but
no matter what i got a ufc contract and
you fought him on the finale when i
thought roy to get into the ufc yeah did
you eat him with hands too i knocked him
out yeah he had full mount on me and
broke my nose
no wait no way that guy managed to break
your nose yeah but yeah i'm surprised
yeah he was so afraid to get punched in
the face he was terrible so it's so
strange terrifying you know someone like
oh this guy will be a [ __ ] killer i
go not if he can't stand getting him
yeah if you don't like getting hit
that's a wrestler's kryptonite man he
could grapple but like he only had one
one move right i don't remember what it
was like straight arm bars
no hell no he's like like [ __ ] the
meat head armor yeah
the nicest guy though yeah he was a nice
guy yeah so there was like a ton of
steelers by the way that were all like
[ __ ] killer wrestling oh cause he
dropped he dropped colby in the second
and that what it was that's why they
gave it to it to him the hook oh i think
so
yeah mazman's still four to one he did
mozville need to work behind his jab
keep his reach going stay busy stay on
the bike get him out of position he got
way too comfortable sitting in there and
then colby just kept putting the
pressure on
never
just relentlessly relentlessly it's dumb
it's his bad fight strategy period with
kobe it's like i you know again i pay
every weekend to watch him in usement so
it's like from here i guess another
hooseman fight that's how it is what
else is that probably but usman you know
he's clearing out the division there's
really no one
foreign edwards dude they fought before
years ago but uh uh uzman called out uh
[ __ ] uh canelo alvarez that's the
greatest thing um that's the greatest
thing because he wants to get knocked
out for a lot of money
marty
you're not beating canelo oh no at all
any round
ever
sorry that's a bad idea yeah that's a
bad idea there's other names we could
throw out there i don't want to throw a
canelo i mean but if you want
anybody but if you're really asking
about it's like well you're going to go
stomp by a boxer in their own sport then
that's weird that's the best you see
always keeping the distance there how
colby was yeah he didn't want to get
tugged over there you noticed that
that's interesting i wonder if he's
still being defensive just in case was
it all still talking about all my three
pieces of [ __ ] code
yeah mozzarella's pure street
how about maswal has the tattoo of him
kneeing ben askress that's [ __ ] dude
you see it's like a jordan tattoo he's
got his own jordan yeah
he does have well he's got a mezcal or
something he's marketing he does yeah
he's tequila and he has his own fight
league in miami i saw big billboards
i was on tour down there i see all over
the billboards like he's got another one
he's got an mma promotion yeah
one of my guys from indianapolis trains
on it
oh wow absolutely why wouldn't they yeah
if it's a matt mitchell guy like hey
this seems like reckless right i'll do
it let's do that
josh did anything in you would you do a
bare knuckle here
yeah of course i mean if the money's
right and whatever like sure that [ __ ]
sounds better knuckles going after
francis yeah they're hard you know they
don't have the money for francis well
they think they do but also who the
[ __ ] going to sign up to fight francis
and barenackle
probably matt matrion i was just saying
josh yeah it might be josh
i mean they don't have a lot of money
for that yeah they have to have a lot of
money trailer uh had the
majority stake yeah they just bought a
majority taken to be to be kfc they
wanted all fight in a [ __ ]
three-sided ring yeah yeah i'm playing
the threesome if i can clinch up i'll
fight they have like resources now
though they have money now all right all
right all right
oh colby called out for you all right
four years ago
but to for pory to come up to seven yeah
so
there's the those one fight doesn't make
too much sense right because they just
fought november yeah so that makes sense
a poirier fight but pory is trying to go
for uh nate diaz
that's interesting
man
yeah i wonder what you gotta say from it
all you just didn't i mean didn't you if
you fought a much smarter fight around
your skill sets i'm not saying he would
have absolutely won but it would have
been way more competitive you know
what's great about mazda although too so
he lost camaro and then he lost to kobe
it's not like it's over he can still
beat the majority
but mario's not going anywhere unless
and and kobe marty has really bad knees
huh yeah bad bad he's had bad knees for
a long time he can't he can't do road
work anything can't condition yeah he's
just basically just
because his knees are so bad the only
knee he's got left him is his weenie and
that's like the only one that he can
really rely on that's it
that's it
happens fast man yeah i like roy man i
think georgia girl all night everybody
here all night
you're opening up for me in nashville
next weekend
we're there weenie
thank you yeah thank you
is that a tune i think that's it right
that's it that's fun josh dude i've won
in the show for a while we got to get
you on a food truck man whatever right
up the street i would love that man did
the the uh fight fight night flashbacks
on that yeah oh hell yeah oh dude that
imagine those we watch your three most
is that we sit around we're just like oh
i can't believe i put myself in this
[ __ ] that's not me matt did but i think
that's what i think yours is gonna be a
little different yeah it's like they sit
around and like you sit here you watch
monitor and it's like your three best
fights and they show the highlights of
it yeah and you talk about going
actually i mean i can i can go through i
would love to do that with you but you
think about it like watching myself
every fan every fan wants to know
your your sentiments like not like not
anybody else but like your sentiments on
this moment like dude you have so much
crazy [ __ ] that has happened in your
life like well think about the fights
being over that's what i'm saying what
like you how do you do three well he's a
legend yeah what do you do i mean is
that an extended is that an extended
show i know i mean if he wants to do six
we'll do six i mean i don't know what
you do yeah what do you say it's gonna
be tough to find three with him i mean
it'd be it'd be so difficult oh like or
like crazy submissions you pull out of
nowhere or like this or like hey would
you go for this like spot just a thought
process everything yeah during the fight
it'd be fun like i think if you ever
think about it like
like the conversation right like that uh
that you'd have with fedor about when he
got slammed by by randleman yeah and the
presence of mind to be like
just go for this and i'll just ask me
how we could we can go into the story
about how me and theodore became friends
that'd be fantastic
yeah it's a story what do you think
fedor's doing right now uh he's probably
at a
orthodox eastern orthodox christian
church praying yeah and then doing a
painting
yeah maybe and then like impregnating
his wife again yeah stud i do love
shopping bro he was when they said every
time he came to america all that dude
does his [ __ ] really we're out
anywhere like we're in new york
everybody's super excited
he's at the gap the original
antagonist for this movie
i trained this girl
for
uh like two months
and she was [ __ ] dynamite for this
thing how really
no oh the original girl the original
girl that shivchenko then took her role
oh i know cats and ghana yeah no no oh
really
oh i thought that was her
uh fighter we know not a fighter at all
oh actress
legit though oh yeah trained her ass off
i trained her in thai boxing and she
sparred in my back patio
twice a week that's so dope dude
she it was her role from the very
beginning but then halle berry came in
no no no it was always a hallelujah the
ufc came in oh oh we want this one in
go figure we need our fighters in the
movie that actress is like [ __ ]
yeah training this [ __ ] she put on
10 15 pounds a good life experience oh
no no for real and i explained i said to
her
this isn't a total loss trust me yeah
you got way better and part of the
training i said look we can train but
you need a spar yeah yeah it's not about
doing patterns so you probably being
comfortable you put her in there and
girls yes
both that's so dope
jesus christ that's my she trains at the
gracie academy yeah that's cool no she's
legit that's dope and an amazing person
her husband
also [ __ ] awesome guys i knew who
this was nothing but great people um by
the way i tried to get chris pratt to go
to you
i tried like when he started grappling
like doing jiu jitsu i was like go to go
to josh like learn catch
here's the thing about pratt so i met
him once yeah he's tall
yeah
great super super nice but here's the
other thing about chris that blew me
away
so batista brought me to the
guardians of the galaxy 2 premiere and
dave's a good dude i've always got we've
we've been friends for a while i guess
you want to go to this i'm like yeah
yeah i [ __ ] i'd love to
and i had said before
online because mo both me and chris are
from washington western washington and
technically he's in the same region as i
was in high school right and he's a
couple years younger than me but he's
within the gap that we could have
wrestled yeah
and i went
i said online hey
pratt prat pratt
i want to know if
if i ever wrestled you
because if i did
that means i smoked you because i smoked
everyone in the region
i was just [ __ ] with them right so i
meet chris
backstage
at this event and i'm like hey dude i
haven't even introduced myself yet and i
go hey gotta ask you this question he
goes i know
did we ever wrestle
he [ __ ] knows everything about me
knows all this stuff
and we got to talk about this wrestle no
he would be so dope he he and i just
kind of missed each other and then his
senior year the 215 guy which was kind
of a newer class at the time is he good
he went to state i think he might i
think he might have taken fifth i've
heard he's pretty damn athletic yeah
he's a legit wrestler yeah um and and
and by the way i'm from seattle so we're
not known for wrestling
at all so it used to be oh you could be
the metro champ which is our district
and then you go to regionals and every
regional guy would just annihilate every
metro kid like they didn't exist right
but i think i might be the
winningest
most successful heavyweight wrestler out
of seattle the city of seattle ever
that's definitely so and again
and i think i think uh seventh and
second or something like that and i
uh won greco state and freestyle and
took second and freestyle i went to
junior nationals both years and all this
stuff so anyways
uh i meet him and i'm like i have to
know did we ever and he knew exactly
what i was [ __ ] talking about i knew
who i was everything and i was like and
then i saw him training at [ __ ]
glazer spot yeah because i will go in
there sometimes and go train uh
unbreakable yeah uh [ __ ] big props to
jay i love you dude and uh
i'm like god damn it he's in here
wrestling [ __ ] hit me up so i can get
in on the mats with [ __ ] pratt i want
to wrestle with him yeah yeah washington
and washington we need to be in here i
don't know if he wants all that heat but
yeah i don't want to give him all that
guy you guys have billionaire train with
him you know
yeah yeah well josh we love you man go
get that wart was it war bringing the
world war master edition master edition
is a santa product warbringer uh on its
own is our 98 proof blend and
this is 112 and we were talking about
like why we choose different proof
levels yeah
this is where it comes out is whatever
it comes out of the barrel at now with
the ttb
anything over a hundred or a hundred and
over
uh i forget what ttb means it has to do
it's like it's basically the the tax and
regulations board of alcohol so this
label has to go through the ttb before
they will approve it being used and
there's all kinds of lingo and stuff
that you can or can't put on it that
they will say no but they will never
tell you if they deny it they will not
say why they'll just say just don't pass
so you got to figure it out yeah
anyways
a hundred proof or over is an additional
tax on to your booze really so
being under 100
keeps you out of that tax so it keeps
your price point a little slightly lower
but for us for at 98 proof with our
blend it's just kind of where it settled
into being what we felt was the best
sipper
and also
um
at like a 60 bottle with standard
warbringer blend maybe you'd call it
expensive to do an old-fashioned but
when you're doing cocktails
old-fashioneds sazerax manhattans
you now have this smoke element built
into it from the mesquite smoked corn
yeah right you're not having to do the
bartender's trick where they light the
smoke and put the glass over them
it's embedded into the whiskey itself
they definitely and they can get it at
what's the can just online uh you can
order online from warbringerbourbon.com
but uh you can also get it at oaks
gourmet in hollywood you can get it knl
wine you can get a mission you get a
remedy you get a lot of locations in and
around l.a and southern california
there's no place in indiana except for
online
probably now see the thing about
distribution is um it is a beast and
every state is like you want to know a
difficult one colorado
colorado is a huge [ __ ] to get yours do
you have tiger thick in colorado yeah do
you from there are you my best friends
are distributors ah there you go or if
you're with like southern wine they get
you and everything but so you know it it
is it is really you know it's
relationships it's it's just i got to
pee like a race no you got to run
the paperwork you got to run through can
be
exacerbated three years
so nuts yeah
but yeah josh love you man uh glad to be
here glad to be here with you man again
brother awesome man hey please thanks a
lot boys it was great time man the best
yeah you crushed it dude i'll be in uh
nashville next week thursday friday
saturday zany's nashville and then i
close the month in chicago but i'm in
zany's uh march 10th in la march yep yep
march uh next wednesday come on out josh
nice nice nice where are you playing
we're gonna go ahead and get tickets for
you uh comedy store or road improv
hollywood improv okay yep that's the
march 9th that's a wednesday and then
next uh this coming thursday night rex
yeah yeah yeah yeah trauma yep and then
chicago's march 24th to 26th that's it
we love you guys we're out see y'all
you